We are back.
It's 2021, after a much needed respite.
Mr. Skolnick and I are in the saddle
with a hotly awaited new edition of "Roll On."
This is the edition of the podcast
where we check in on our respective goings on,
pontificate on certain current events of interest.
We share some wins, do a little show and tell
and as always, answer some listener/viewer questions
from our voicemail,
which you can ring up at (424) 235-4626.
Before we get into it,
quick reminder that if you enjoy
all the free content that we diligently toil,
week-in, week-out, to create,
it would be very meaningful and easy for you
if you could take a second to hit the subscribe button
on YouTube or wherever you enjoy
the audio incarnation of the show.
Leave a comment, share the show with your friends
or on social media.
Also, I should mention,
we recently created a clips channel on YouTube
which is rather anemic right now in terms of subscribers.
So if you're into sampling the show or you wanna indulge
in just the short nuggets, check it out.
I'll put a link in the show notes
and in the description below on YouTube
or you can just search Rich Roll podcast clips on YouTube.
Today is very exciting.
We have a tweak on the tweak of our "Roll On" format.
We're gonna try something new today.
For the first time in the history of "Roll On",
how many "Roll On" episodes have we done, Adam?
I think it's like over a dozen.
I thought it was 14, 13, 14-
Is it that many?
Something like that, yeah.
Wow.
I know.
We have some momentum here.
Well, today we're gonna bring on
a couple of guests in a few,
Arthur Jones and Giorgio Angelini,
who you guys know as the filmmakers
behind the wonderful movie, "Feels Good Man".
You're most likely familiar with them,
if not from the movie,
from a recent episode of the podcast,
which, although it just posted the other day,
we actually recorded it back in early December,
sometime in December.
So I haven't seen these guys for a minute,
even though they're just up on the podcast the other week.
These guys are our internet culture decoder ring
and they're coming in hot to help us make sense
of a few crazy, recent events.
Just a few, just culture.
In culture.
Right?
Just a few.
But first Adam, how are you doing?
I'm good.
You know, I just subscribed to the YouTube channel
earlier today.
The clip's channel?
No, the original YouTube channel. (laughing)
It took you this long?
You're actually on the show.
You don't even subscribe?
I don't subscribe to myself.
Here's the thing.
Like when you look at the analytics on our YouTube channel,
we're doing great.
But like something like 96%
of the watches are from people
that don't subscribe to the channel.
Is that right?
Which is odd.
So come on you guys.
Subscribe.
Yeah.
Look how long it took you to do it.
But you have a pretty, I know.
I'm embarrassed about it, but you have a pretty good,
it seems like the subscriptions are pretty solid
on the main account.
It's doing well.
We're in a groove right now.
As I tweeted the other day
or shared the other day,
the Andrew Huberman podcast eclipsed four million views.
It's gonna hit like 4.5 in another couple of days
or something like that.
Yeah, I thought it was 4.5 today, already.
Is it 4.5-
I thought it was when I checked today.
Something like that.
It's insane.
Like, that podcast was,
I don't know, nine months ago or something like that.
And it's still cranking the YouTube algorithm gods
for whatever reason.
Maybe Arthur and Georgio can help us figure this out.
Like, I don't know why they decided that one.
It's a great episode, of course,
but that one is crushing out there
and it's bringing all kinds of new people to the show
which is cool.
Fantastic.
Welcome, new people.
But, back to my question.
How are you doing?
You know, everything is good.
Let's see, I took January, like you,
just a little bit half-speed.
I was working, you know, maybe 15, 20 hours
or at least that was the plan,
was to just do some reading,
catch up on some books
that I've been wanting to read forever.
And kinda pitch in a bit more with Zoom on,
hang out with a family a bit more.
And then, all hell broke loose in Washington.
And I was like, glued to the television for days on end,
doom scrolling.
(Rich laughing)
So that was my downtime.
It was impossible not to do that.
It was impossible from January 6th to the 20th,
I was like, I couldn't do anything.
I know.
It was crazy.
But ran a lot around, you know,
maybe 110 miles this last month.
That's gotta be your biggest month.
Biggest month ever running.
You're looking svelte.
Hey, thanks, man.
I mean, it's only two, so I'm not that svelte,
but yeah, so that's good.
And Zoom is doing well and you know,
my wife wants to buy a house, so, you know,
I'm growing up.
You're living dream.
The adult dream, right?
Late comer to the adult world.
And maybe if you weren't so late to GameStop,
you could be buying that house right now.
You know, it's possible. (laughing)
I have some material for GameStop,
so I'll hold all materials.
Cool.
Well, this is my first podcast after taking,
essentially, an entire month off to Hawaii.
Yes, like how are you?
I'm good, I feel really good.
I feel refreshed.
I feel energized.
It was certainly needed.
I wouldn't say I was teetering on burnout,
but I definitely needed a break.
I'd been grinding the entire year
without taking any time off, whatsoever.
Wow.
So.
Do you get like one day off a week, generally?
Or not even?
I pretty much work every,
I mean every once in a while I'll take a day off
and I do,
like, there'll be,
like in the middle of the week,
pre-pandemic, I would like go to a matinee
or like just take little mini breaks.
And on the weekends, I work less,
but the show goes up every Sunday night.
So typically, there's a scramble on Sunday afternoon
to kind of do last minute tweaks on the show to get it up.
So I feel like I'm always kind of working.
So one of the goals, I'll get into my break,
but one of the goals for this year
is to really utilize
this new studio and the manpower that we have now
to systematize and make things more efficient
and create, you know, a little bit more bandwidth
for intermittent rest.
Yeah.
Throughout the year and the weeks.
But yeah, I took a month off.
I started this, the year before.
I went to Australia for the month of December.
This year, I decided to go to Hawaii for January.
Solo or did you bring the family?
Well, Mathis went with me for a week.
She had a friend that she was with.
She went back and then, I was solo the whole time.
And it was fantastic.
When's the last time that's been that way? (laughing)
First I will say, I got tested a lot of times.
So I did it safely.
Hawaii has things pretty dialed in.
If you go to Kauai, you gotta quarantine for 14 days.
But on the other islands,
they require that you get a test within 72 hours,
you gotta fill out all this paperwork, you get a QR code.
When you land in the airport,
you've got to show them all the paperwork.
They scan your QR code
and they test you in the airport.
Hmm.
Before you can even get to baggage claim.
Right.
So they have it.
If you're on an island,
you can control things a little bit better.
And the case incidents on the big island was very low.
It was something like 10 to 30 a day.
And people were wearing masks everywhere you went,
if you went inside somewhere,
but overall it felt much safer to be there.
I'm sure.
And I was just in my own-
You mean safer than the hot zone
on planet Earth? (laughing)
Of Los Angeles?
Yeah, I got out of LA.
And it was good.
You know, I just took care of myself
and you know, rented a bike and rode and ran
and swam in the ocean, swam with dolphins,
which was incredible.
You just rented like a high-end bike
from a good bike shop or something?
I did.
There's a shop called Bike Works in Kona.
And I have a good relationship with them
because I've spent so much time there
and raced there so many times.
So Grant, who owns Bike Works, is a friend
and he hooked me up with a super sweet ride.
That's cool.
So that was great.
And just went out of my way to not create
an agenda for myself.
Like I have friends there
and I saw a couple of friends,
but, I tried to not commit myself to anything.
And to double down,
like to go out of my way to not work,
which is its own effort.
Right, yeah, it took effort, right?
And I do wanna highlight like swimming with dolphins.
I've been open water swimming, like my whole life.
Never had the experience of swimming with dolphins ever.
Never?
And I just was out off the Kailua Pier
where they do the Ironman Swim
and found myself in a pod of like 40 to 50 dolphins.
It was like, unbelievable.
Were they spinners?
Were they spinning around?
They weren't.
I didn't see a lot of spinning
but they were like at all depths
and just playing with each other and surfacing.
And it was just the coolest thing.
That is the coolest thing.
So that experience alone made the whole thing worth it.
The Kona coast is known for that, right?
'Cause they have Kona, now,
which is two-step where the free divers go
just past Captain Cook,
if you go South from Kona.
Right, I know Captain Cook, yeah.
They are known to have spinners around.
"Voices in the Ocean", that Susan Casey book,
which is about dolphins.
There's a woman who works out of Kona
and does these charters where people go
and like, it's very controversial in Kona.
Like, not every diver likes this woman, I forget her name.
But like she takes these people out
to swim with dolphins off boats.
And like, she has people,
like, she talks to the dolphins
and sings like, dolphin songs
and the dolphins come or something.
Oh, wow.
And I saw one of her acolytes, not in a bad way,
like one of her disciples, I guess,
in the Kona, now once,
and I remember, April and I had just gotten in
not too long ago.
I was out there for work.
And this woman is like singing in the water
and I'm like, what is she doing?
At first, she seemed a little kooky,
the snorkeler just singing like, dolphin songs
or whatever, squeaking. (laughing)
And all of a sudden, the dolphins came right to her.
So I just stuck with her, you know,
I stuck with this, you know, eccentric dolphin singer.
But, why is she controversial?
That just sounds cool.
It's controversial because some people just are haters,
you know, it is cool.
Right.
And some people are haters
and they think like, oh, you know, they don't believe it.
And you know, there's like,
you gotta read "Voices in the Ocean".
There is a spiritual side to it.
There is like a whole thing beyond just like,
hey, it's cool to swim with dolphins.
Right
But, yeah.
There's a hater aspect to it around there,
but it's mostly, I've found,
like the women who are free divers there,
they like it.
They like the woman.
They liked the people.
And the men are the ones that are dismissive.
That's not shocking.
No.
Right.
Who's the free diver instructor coach guy
that I texted you about
who was doing a course in Kona-
Kurt Chambers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So my friend Anthony Ervin who's in Oahu
or was at the time, I think he still is,
I think did something with him
and alerted me to this guy.
And I was tempted to take the guy's course,
but then I was like,
I really just need to rest and not doing anything.
So I opted out of that.
Yeah, Kurt broke Nick Mevoli's American record.
I think he might still hold it
or he held it for a while,
as the deepest American ever.
Wow.
Of free diving over a hundred meters.
He competed at Team USA.
He's in one breath, in kind of, just an side.
Interesting guy.
Great, great photographer.
And a very prolific teacher out there.
Right, he has a cool Instagram, too.
Yeah, very cool.
"ChambersBelow".
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
@ChambersBelow.
Yeah.
But the upshot is, I'm back.
I feel energized.
I feel fit.
I've got good momentum with my fitness.
I'm excited about 2021.
I do wanna take a moment to welcome Jason Camiolo.
Yes.
To the studio.
Jason, for people that have been on this podcast journey
with us for a while,
know him as the audio engineer/producer/guy
who takes care of all kinds of behind the scenes stuff.
He had always been living in the Phoenix area
and all of our work was remotely performed.
And now he has moved to Los Angeles and he's here full-time,
manning all the dials right now.
So, welcome Jason.
We're excited to have you
and it's gonna be an amazing year.
So, I'm pumped.
Can I ask you one more question about Hawaii?
Yeah.
Were are you getting Ironman pangs
like being on the terrain?
I mean, you're basically riding and running and swimming
similar terrain, is it?
Yeah, but I spent so much time on the big island.
Like for me,
it's not that exotic to go there
because I have logged so many hours training there
and just like living there, basically.
So it's more like a feeling of coming home.
Like it's nice to ride on the Queen K.
And I got off the beaten track and did some other rides
and tried to explore other aspects of the island
that I'm less familiar with,
but it's very like comfortable for me to just go there.
And it doesn't feel like vacation.
It just feels like another place
that I've lived in the past.
Yeah.
So.
How is the water?
So good.
76, 78.
Yeah, and there were whales breaching.
I was in a condo for half the time
and then on this beautiful house on the water
in a little neighborhood called Keapuka.
which is a pretty cool area.
Is that north of Kona or south?
It's north.
It's just South of Hapuna Beach and Kuahiwi,
if you know where that is.
So right, kind of a couple of miles before the Kuahiwi turn,
if you know the island at all,
but it's this little like hidden neighborhood
with all these beautiful homes right on the water
and whales breaching off of it, it was crazy.
So you didn't leave? (laughing)
But, part of the goal was to, you know,
be off digital devices
and, you know, really live an analog life.
But the world exploded and like yourself,
I found myself doom scrolling
and I could not detach myself from the news cycle,
which seemed to be just, you know,
getting crazier, you know, by the second,
which is what we're gonna get into right now.
It went goofier than anyone even thought,
like, you could say that about the entire presidency
or the last four years,
it went goofier than we ever thought.
But like the end. (laughing)
It was like a fireworks,
you know, when they have a firework show?
It was like the finale to the firework show.
A little bit, right? (laughing)
So, shall we now just dispel the idea
that somehow 2021 might normalize?
That everything is gonna get kind of, settle into place?
Instead, we give you insurrection, game stunk,
Jewish lasers and who knows else?
And who knows what else?
So let's take a quick break.
And when we come back,
we'll be joined by Giorgio and Aurthur.
(air whooshing)
All right.
And we're back with the boys.
Four in the house.
We got Arthur, we got Giorgio.
I'm disappointed, Giorgio, though.
I was told that you were gonna dress up today
as the QAnon Shaman.
Yeah, I had my top down on my convertible.
Didn't happen?
The helmet flew off.
The Viking horns.
Somewhere on the 101 now, so.
Say what you want about the QAnon Shaman,
but at least he eats organic.
He's organic, right?
Wasn't he on a food strike?
Yes, yes.
When he was incarcerated?
Yes.
What's the latest update on that guy?
Well, there was a fake news.
So a friend of mine sent me a National Post article
which is some bullshit tabloid from Canada
that tried to claim that the judge actually gave it to him.
Gave him organic food?
And that started proliferating through social media
and outraging people, you know,
how could he get this special treatment?
They would never treat a POC that way, blah, blah, blah.
But it turns out, he didn't get it.
Wasn't true.
No.
I think he's agreed to be deposed in Congress
and like speak against, I guess, presumably Trump,
like speak to the movement.
Hmm, wow.
So that should be interesting.
For sure, he'll take it to an invitation to a microphone.
Exactly. (laughing)
He had been building his brand for a while.
Like, I mean, he'd been showing up
to all the save your children rallies
for months before the Capitol insurgence.
I mean, he kind of is the face of the whole thing
on some level.
This has to be going exactly as he hoped it would,
I would imagine that.
Perhaps.
Until he ends up behind bars, I suppose.
I don't know he pondered on that aspect.
Well, his lawyer is ahead of that.
His lawyer said, you know,
he's not a bad person.
He's a practitioner of yoga.
That was one of the early defense lines.
No?
I swear to God.
Just like the beaker guy, right?
Well, it feels a little bit-
(guys chattering)
It feels a little bit weird and dated
to like talk about the Capitol insurrection
'cause it feels like it's a hundred years ago.
Could you have imagined when that was going on that,
you know, a month later it would feel like old news
in comparison to some of the things that are happening now?
It's just crazy, right?
I do think we need to like track it a little bit
but what I wanted you guys here for
is to help us understand or like decode, you know,
how we move from Peppe the Frog,
how that becomes Qanon,
how that leads to the insurrection
and the interrelation between that
or the interplay between that
and kind of what we're seeing right now with GameStop
and the gamification of Wall Street.
I mean, it's insane.
It is insane, but it is also-
That's a lot of ground to cover.
Right.
Yeah.
No, it's true.
There's that amazing meme of,
it's someone standing in front of a line of dominoes
and the first domino's very small
and the last domino's is very huge.
And the beginning push of the domino on the small domino
is basically Gamergate
and then the final one is all of the COVID deaths.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Elon Musk tweeted that graphic, right, yeah.
Oops. (laughing)
He's somewhere in the middle of that.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Well, he's a player right now.
Right.
Absolutely.
He's basically front and center
in terms of like which memes get traction and which don't.
He's a merchant of chaos at this point.
But chaos is a good place to start.
Like where were you all,
where were you guys like, Rich, when it started happening
and the riots broke out,
I mean, I think we should start there.
Like, where were you?
What were you guys thinking?
I mean, I was in Hawaii trying to be off the computer
and off my phone
and I just could not stop getting calendars.
Were you getting texts first
or how'd you find out about it?
No, I mean, I would check in.
It wasn't like I was trying to be completely off the phone
but you know, I would look at Twitter and then, you know,
you'd see the news and you're like,
I have to understand what's happening,
like, I just could not put distance
between myself and the device.
It was just so compelling
and strange and interesting
and disheartening and unbelievable.
Like, every adjective under the hood.
Yeah, the guy in our film, Joel,
who is part of the network contagion,
wait, what's that, I can't remember the acronym.
I don't remember.
I mean, he works out at Princeton.
He has a consortium of people called iDRAMA Lab.
And they had been modeling behavior
on all of these different platforms.
And so, a lot of this stuff I think was predictable
by the academics that followed it.
And it was also predictable
because this notion of Stop the Steal,
specifically, when Trump addressed the crowd,
he talked about Stop the Steal.
And he's like, this is something you came up with,
but the reality of Stop the Steal is that started in 2016.
That was something that was something
that Roger Stone came up.
Hmm, before the election?
Yeah, well, they assumed,
I think a lot of people assumed that the race
with Hillary Clinton was gonna be very close.
And so they were already seeding this notion
of Stop the Steal that early,
the point where Stone bought the URL.
And so this idea that this was like an organic groundswell
is ridiculous.
Stop the Steal was also used sort of in the midterms.
So they're just kind of pulling on the same thread
that's been there for a while,
but I don't think anyone could have predicted
that the Capitol police response would have been so lax.
But I think this was a moment of coalition building
where they had all of the oath keepers, the Proud Boys,
all the QAnon people, all the Christian fundamentalists,
the white supremacists,
all sort of merging around this one thing.
And, you know, in the weeks before,
you know, we can't forget that all of these people
were coming to different state capitals
and showing up in real life as well, so.
And it was the day
that they were supposed to certify, right?
So everything was kind of,
we knew they were all going there.
That's why we were all tuned in to begin with.
Like, it wasn't like I wasn't gonna watch the news
that day anyway.
Right.
So it was almost like plot twist. (laughing)
But the inauguration was meant to be
the ultimate moment in QAnon history.
Right.
Right?
It was all supposed to go down at that moment.
So there was a lot of energy
and anticipation that was circling around all of that.
And in terms of the Capitol police response,
like the wake of what transpired,
you saw all of these internet sleuths
sharing screen grabs from 4chan.
And it's like, anybody who spent any time
or exerted any due diligence leading up to the inauguration
could have easily discovered that this was,
you know, a possibility
or more more likely than not, like a plausibility.
And so where is like,
where does the fault get levied
in terms of that anemic, you know, kind of response?
I'd say, cops.
Yeah.
I think that remains to be seen.
I mean, they haven't released surveillance.
Today, something came out because tomorrow,
I guess, the impeachment proceedings
or the trial begins.
Right and all his lawyers quit, right?
Because he wants to maintain the Stop the Steal argument.
And they just can't abide by that.
So now he's got these new-
They don't wanna lose their standing at the bar.
So Don Winslow tweeted out a letter
that looked accurate to me,
but it was from Christopher Miller,
the Defense Secretary,
or the Army Secretary,
someone else had just left that post.
And he got put in as the acting Secretary.
And in this letter, it basically said,
it was before January 6th,
it was before January 4th,
there had been requests to have National Guard on standby.
And then in this letter, he basically is saying,
you can't have any of that on standby.
You need to clear everything through me
or nothing happens at all.
And there is a paper trail.
So that was the first thing that dropped.
And that just happened right before I got here today.
Jesus.
On Twitter.
So if you look on Don Winslow's Twitter, you know,
the guy that wrote the cartel books.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well yeah, I mean, so Joel from our film,
reached out to me like a year ago
and he's been researching Q, this whole time.
And he basically told me that a year ago,
that at that stage, like,
that QAnon was essentially like fully operational
at this point.
And the thing that was very concerning
from his perspective was that
it was kind of the first time
that there's a leaderless movement like this
and that it was kind of irrelevant
whether or not people discovered who Q himself
or herself was at that point,
because it was like the self-aggregating,
self-motivated machine.
And that's like, what the capital insurrection
sort of proved out because at that point,
Q hadn't really spoken at that point in like a month.
And yeah, where do we go from here?
Who knows, but.
Well, what was important though,
was that the Q prophecy was actualized
and that certainly did not come to pass.
So this bubble gets popped.
And then you have a fracture in that community.
You have the hardcores who are still reconfiguring
the narrative to say, well, because of this and this,
like, it's still a thing.
And then you have a whole other larger fraction
of that population coming to their senses.
And now we're seeing like,
did you see the Anderson Cooper interview
with the former QAnon guy who had to apologize to him
for thinking that he ate babies?
And we're seeing a lot of that right now
which is kind of encouraging, I think, on some level,
but it had to be fascinating for you guys
who are so steeped in all of this
to kind of watch that transpire knowing what you guys know
about the power of these movements
that, you know, for the most part,
don't catch the attention of mainstream society.
I mean, Adam, you were saying you were,
before the pockets, you were talking about
how you were researching voting.
Yeah.
For a book proposal.
And you didn't even know anything about it.
I didn't know about Peppe, no.
I was spending a lot of time in the ocean though, in 2016.
So.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
You know, right down the street from my house. (laughing)
So I don't know.
I wasn't like on the Q, I wasn't in the 4chan.
'Cause like by then, I think we'd had,
I mean, this goes to why it's important
to dive into this like darker kind of murky,
shitty stuff, right, as awake human beings.
It's great that you're talking about this
because you'd think like when you,
4chan, I always associate it
with the UC Santa Barbara mass shooter
who, you know, these incels
and like these righteous, self-righteous incels.
And I just like, I don't want anything to do with that.
So I kind of tune that stuff out.
So when I'm looking at an election
that happened with how Trump won,
I wasn't looking at like 4chan at all.
It wasn't even on my radar.
My radar was like, how could,
I was thinking way analog, I was like-
Gerrymandering.
You know, I'm not a gamer.
Pacs.
I'm not into that word.
So I wasn't thinking like that at all.
So to, which is why I love the movie so much
because it wakes you up.
And this shows like if we'd been tuned in,
if the Republican party had been tuned in,
maybe like, if anybody had been tuned in,
it could have been stopped,
but maybe it couldn't have been, you know,
maybe it was like, when you have a groundswell like this,
there's nothing that can stop it.
I don't know that they were necessarily against-
I was gonna say, I think they were tuned in,
I think they chose to ignore it.
Yeah.
And I think there's evidence of that.
I mean, you know, we've been in contact
with this Republican congressmen, Denver Riggleman,
who was the one sort of voice in the wilderness,
the one Republican that spoke out against Q over the summer.
And he claims that he was basically chastised
by the rest of the party.
They told them to stop talking about Q
because they felt like that was their margin
in certain states.
And so, you know, he tweeted out and said that,
you know, Q, there was no coincidence that Q
had the same number of letters as moron.
Qanon.
Qanon, excuse me.
And then also, that it's mental gonorrhea.
And so, you know, the Republicans, I think knew this,
but they realized that it was something
that was to their advantage.
Yeah, I mean, and to back up, I mean,
to the kind of incel shooter aspect of Qanon
and sort of the nexus of when these two coalitions,
the 4chan community and like,
the burgeoning Trump movement coincided,
in the film, we kind of tease it out
but sometimes it just whizzes past people.
So it's worth refocusing on it here
'cause it's really central to the conversation,
but it's like,
there's a mass shooting in Oregon in 20-
15.
2015.
And we don't know for sure,
but most likely the shooter himself posted on 4chan,
a kind of warning that like, don't go to school tomorrow.
There's gonna be a shooting.
And then at the bottom, there's Peppe holding a handgun.
And then two weeks later,
Donald Trump, who at that point,
is like a dark horse candidate,
posts a meme of himself as like smug Peppe.
And for a lot of people, like, first of all,
that was the first time that Peppe really made it
into the national news, was during that shooting.
But people didn't really know what it was.
He was referred to as a Grinch,
a sniveling Grinch or something?
Right?
Yes.
Yeah, but then also, like,
people didn't really understand the significance
of what Trump was tweeting, but in a sense,
it was a kind of wink to this collective of online trolls
that were really the Vanguard
of like hacking the internet at that point, right.
And like the burgeoning click-based economy.
Like they really understood, they were very savvy
at understanding how to manipulate the flows of media.
And so Trump, at that moment, under,
or, well, who knows?
If there's one question I would ask Trump, it's like,
did you know what you were tweeting at that point?
Yeah, the self-awareness around that is up in the air.
Totally, totally dubious.
But like, you know, Peppe at that point,
represented something very significant.
It was kind of like a preemptor
to the stand back and stand by moment, right?
And so what he really set off
was this kind of wink to that community
who all shared a similar sort of
hatred towards PC culture and, you know,
minorities and women.
And they all kind of shared the same anger
towards the same group of people.
And he, those people, basically started creating like,
a meme revolution that helped him kind of
buttress this burgeoning movement of online mean Lords
into like, you know, a actual political movement.
As older people are starting to join social media and stuff,
they started like, oh, what's this funny frog meme?
You know, this is fun.
And you start to realize that like,
memes are actually really incredible ways
to like capture the imagination of people
and like kind of coalesce around a movement
around mean iconography, I guess.
So, what's the connection?
Where's the link from Peppe,
like you were asking, from Peppe to Q?
When does that happen?
When does that start happening?
Is there a direct link
where Peppe becomes like a Q, basically?
Well, Peppe in the constellation Of Q iconography,
Peppe is sort of a satellite figure.
You know, it is interesting.
So Peppe became very popular on 4chan
and that's where Q started, too.
Q started out as one of many jokes
where people on 4chan,
they pretend to be someone they're not
and they post using various sort of aliases.
And so people would post often on 4chan,
pretending to have like some sort of government access
or secret knowledge.
And usually, this is all taken as like a larp or a joke,
but Q really started off, you know,
when a group of people, when a sort of cohort of people
who were all trying to create their own persona
is very much based on info wars,
kind of found these Q drops
and they started to signal boost them
within their YouTube live streams,
on Twitter and these sorts of places.
And then you started to see Q resonating
with a different audience than Peppe resonated with.
Peppe resonated with a younger audience,
an internet savvy audience,
an audience that was like very irony,
you know, like very irony poisoned.
Q found sort of an audience of an older generation,
most of whom were evangelical Christians.
And they were looking for some sort of way
in which Trump was gonna be part of God's plan,
was basically gonna be their savior, essentially.
And the narrative of Q was that,
ignore all of the hypocrisy, the corruption,
you know, ignore all of that because Trump has actually
kind of running a covert deep state
sort of espionage sting
where he's gonna sort of show up triumphant.
He's gonna maybe kill Hillary Clinton,
maybe hang her, maybe imprison her,
different people thought different things.
And so this was a moment where
this really like caught wildfire in Facebook groups
and it caught wildfire in Twitter.
It was another moment where things moved off of 4chan
and into the mainstream.
And while this was happening,
a lot of the old school people that were using Peppe,
maybe in our film, were just laughing.
They were like,
I can't believe these people believe this stuff.
This is 2017, maybe?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
And so, you know, you started to then see
the people who were Q adherence
really got kind of addicted to the same like online behavior
that a lot of the 4chan people were kind of,
you know, it's the same stuff that was
the shut-in culture of 4chan.
The people that were spending all their time online,
this was now happening with a slightly older generation,
and they were following themselves,
they were going down a rabbit hole.
They would call themselves white rabbits
or they would say follow the white rabbit.
And it was this willful, kind of crazy-making
where it was exciting and fun to feel
like you were part of this other movement.
And while this was happening,
this is fitting it into like Biblical revelation.
It's fitting into a lot of other sort of presumed prophecy
that people are already thinking about.
Just a general good versus evil, right?
Yeah, the revelation's parallel,
I think, is pretty powerful.
Like it was all gonna culminate in this reckoning.
Right.
And Trump 5D Chess maneuvers were gonna come to play
and everything was gonna change.
And Trump represents this really great,
kind of imperfect hero, right,
which I think is like very familiar
kind of character within evangelical community, right?
Like you kind of explain a way the fact
that he's been married three times
and he's a pathological liar.
He's like an imperfect person
under the light of Christ or whatever.
Well and he's viewed as a protector, you know.
I mean, he delivered this Supreme Court nominations,
you know, one third of the Supreme court now is,
you know-
Oops.
Yeah, is now Trump appointees.
There were certain things that he was doing
that were really viewed as he was a protector
of Christian America, whether and they knew he was-
White, Christina America, right?
Very much so.
Yeah, yeah.
Right.
I mean, for single issue voters where it's all about,
pro-life, it's much easier for them to overlook
all the other indiscretions
because he's taking care of that issue for them.
Yeah and then, of course COVID happens
and then just hyper charges all of this
because now you can't leave your house
and you're stuck inside of your computer.
And like the funnel, you know,
just gets tighter and tighter.
But that's kerosene on-
The funnel gets tighter but the mouth gets wider.
That's kerosene on the community aspect of this
which I think is super important,
whether it's 4chan and Peppe
or Facebook groups and QAnon,
it gave these people something to engage with
and created like a really robust community
that provided a sense of belonging,
that gamified the whole thing.
And on some level, I suppose, was addictive
and just too compelling to not walk away from.
It was extremely addictive.
Yeah, there's an alienation problem in America.
I think for a lot of people,
that pre-existed COVID, right?
We are a culture that spends more time
commuting than any other culture in our cars, by ourselves.
You know, like, the film we worked on together,
the previous film was about housing.
And like one of the central points of,
central data points that really fascinated me,
that got me into the making of the film was the idea that
60 years ago, the average size of the family
was three and a half people.
And the average size of the home was 900 square feet.
And today, it's two and a half people
and it's almost 3000 square feet.
So we have like fewer people inhabiting more space.
And like, there's just something inherently distressing
and alienating about that.
And I think like QAnon just kind of
exacerbates all these problems
and then COVID layers on top of it.
And all of a sudden you feel like you're part of a community
solving this global cabal of pedophiles.
And it like, it becomes inescapable, the seduction.
Yeah, I mean, I think in addition to the alienation
and the disconnection that so many people experience,
it also gave a lot of moraless people
a sense of purpose, right?
Like, I'm thinking of Klete Keller, you know,
he got a lot of attention, the Olympic swimmer
who showed up in the rotunda.
I don't know him personally
but I have lots of friends that do know him well.
And this is a guy who
excelled at the highest level in his sport,
went to multiple Olympiads, metaled,
like a huge athletic champion.
And then in the wake of retiring,
hit like some really tough experiences.
He got divorced, he lost custody of his kids,
at one point for an extended period of time,
he was homeless living in his car.
He could not find his groove with his career.
And he couldn't supplant the sense of purpose
that he found in swimming in other areas of his life.
And in so many ways,
he's almost like the perfect test case
for somebody who's gonna be susceptible
to these kinds of ideas.
Like I tweeted about him being
kind of the convergence
of Kevin Russo's rabbit hole podcast series
with "The Weight of Gold", HBO documentary.
Like he experienced what so many Olympians experience
when they retire,
they have mental health issues,
they have depression,
they can't figure out what to do with their lives,
meets, you know, QAnon or these other ideas
and then there you go, down the rabbit hole
and he shows up in the rotunda
and thinks it's a good idea
to be wearing his Olympic jacket, you know, at the time.
So what is the mentality of somebody like that?
And I'm trying, when I look at that,
I'm trying to look at it from a perspective
of compassion and curiosity.
Like, I wanna understand what led him to that place
rather than just vilify him.
No, like there's something,
obviously, there's a huge mental health component
that we're touching on here,
the alienation, you know,
this specific case,
but everybody there, was part of this,
who decided to enter the rotunda,
whether they planned to in advance,
which there's certainly evidence that a lot,
some of them did.
I mean, a lot of them did.
Or whether they just happened to get caught up.
There's something about this,
a performative attempt to create an alternate reality
that you are starring in.
And whether, you know, you see people streaming themselves,
Klete is wearing his outfit.
So you knew the Qanon Shaman made sure you knew who he was.
People are like, you know, Darren, what's his face,
Darren's in the rotunda.
You know, the guy from West Virginia.
There's something about a pride to be a part of this
kind of alternate reality
that they managed to create together
where anything could have happened.
I mean, like really, anything could have happened.
Like if they had run into AOC or Pelosi or Pence,
there would have been bloodshed, for sure.
But in reality, it was just people milling around
and doing kind of just vandalizing
is what ended up happening.
But fueled by a sense of righteousness.
That's why they were so brazen about taking the selfies
and live streaming it because in their minds,
they were doing the right thing.
And that Trump would protect them.
Trump and Cruz and all these other people who,
in their minds, had discharged them for this purpose.
Yep.
Yeah.
I was listening to a podcast recently
called "Design Matters", and Marina Abramovic was on
and she was talking about her piece in 1974,
this famous performance art piece that she did in Naples,
which maybe you've heard about.
But like, she basically erected this stage
and laid out a bunch of different things in front of her
and basically invited the audience
to do whatever they wanted to her.
There was no rules.
But the only agreement was that you were coming up on stage
so you were part of the performance.
And it went on for six hours and I'd heard, you know,
descriptions of the performance before
but I'd never heard it from her perspective.
And what was really striking to me was like
her description of what happened afterwards,
because during the performance,
things escalated like very quickly.
And, you know, she was fearful that she was gonna get raped.
A guy at a certain point,
picked up the the revolver that was on the thing
and put it up to her head and someone intervened
and pulled it out of his hand.
And she got cut on the neck
and someone like sucked the blood out of her neck.
And then she said, that at a moment where she thought
she was gonna get raped,
women in the audience were yelling at the men
on stage to do something to her, like something terrible.
But so after the performance concluded,
she walked out into the audience
and no one could look at her in the eye.
Everyone was so ashamed at what they had done.
And I was like, that is the capital insurrection.
It's like the shock treatment test,
that became a shock treatment test.
Or it's the Stanford prison experiment.
Yeah, Trump gave them-
(men chattering)
Trump gave him the permission and you hear it now
when like after these people were arrested,
they were like, well Trump said I could do it.
Right.
And like that is a really powerful-
Yeah, the sheer incredulity that they would be held
to account for these actions, like the surprise,
like wait a minute, what do you mean?
Why is the FBI calling me?
Exactly.
Confusion.
The guy crying in the airport terminal, because he got,
he was already on the no fly-
He got on the no fly list.
Yeah.
But the thing is, Trump didn't specifically say
they could do that.
And so like, I'm not defending him.
I'm not defending him, I'm not defending him.
But the whole culture is about cryptic drops, right?
Where you have to read the tea leaves.
Yes and there's a reason he's the best conman in history.
He knows what not to say and how to say
what he's not saying.
(men laughing)
Yeah, and get off scot-free every time.
Right, yeah, it's wild.
I mean, Q sort of now, I think,
doesn't necessarily represent sort of the adrenochrome
and the baby blood and all that sort of stuff anymore.
Now it's just basically, you're signaling to the world
that you have some sort of,
a spiritual war against the deep state,
that you are a person who feels as though
you are working on behalf of divinity in some way.
And so over the summer, it went from the evangelicals
to kind of a new age crowd.
And within that new age crowd,
it was a lot of influencers, as well.
Q initially was a lot of people alone
in their Facebook groups, trading Q drops.
And then over the summer,
it really moved into a street movement.
And it had like a slight,
it had a different group of people
who are attached to it at that point.
And I think a lot of those people who are in the rotunda
started from those sorts of protests
that were happening during the summer,
the anti-lock down protests.
Yeah.
Those sorts of protests.
And people were oblivious to their own sedition,
at that point.
They did not understand what they were doing.
They couldn't define sedition if you ask them to,
most of these people.
I mean, let's not be super nice.
Like, there are some morons in this group,
like there's some real idiots.
For sure.
I mean, they're not bright.
And some truly evil people doing it.
I mean, you can't under,
count the fact that they're amongst the group of clueless,
like just sort of live streaming. (laughing)
Well, it certainly wasn't a monolith.
Like, you had, there were Appleheads
who stumbled in there accidentally
and just thought it was like a frat party.
And then you have the highly trained, you know,
super militarized group of people
who are wearing ear pieces and have zip ties
and look like they're in military formation
going into the Capitol.
Like, those are two different types of people.
And then there's just like the baby boomers
that are like, thought it would be fun to go to a protest.
Right, I mean seriously.
Right, yeah.
(men chattering)
I mean, I have some friends who found out afterwards
that their parents were there.
They weren't like part of the siege,
but they were there and then they left
before things went really bananas.
Or, so they say.
Yeah, or so they say.
And then went to the Hyatt Regency
and had a Chardonnay, yeah.
Yeah.
In the lobby.
Yeah, I mean, I guess the larger issue is, you know,
like I have a bunch of family who are very conservative
and they would sort of watch the Capitol riots
with a lot of the same sort of surprise
and revulsion that maybe we would,
but ultimately, they're sympathetic,
because they do feel like the election was stolen.
They do feel like Biden doesn't have a mandate
from the people.
And I don't know what you do with that thinking.
Right, so,
in the settling of the dust,
are we in a situation in which
there's a calcification of, you know,
like a doubling down on these ideas
by a certain subset of this group?
Or is there a moment of awakening happening
where people are just coming to their senses?
Like, what is your,
you know, how do you take the temperature right now
on the culture in terms of what that produced
and what will happen next?
I mean, for me personally,
I think it just has to come from accountability.
I think the Republicans are still, you know,
for like a day after that,
there was like, just like little breadcrumbs
that they were offering up to the public
for like, I don't know,
like recognition that this was maybe,
had gone a little bit too far,
but that was immediately erased like the next day.
And now they're saying like, oh, let's just get over this.
Why are you gonna impeach the president?
He's just a private citizen now.
So like the reality is
that the Republican party has always been a party of trolls.
And like now, it's just only intensified
and they can't sort of relinquish that power
because to do that is to admit
that they're actually not interested in governing, right?
Like they want all of the power of being in office
but they don't want any of the responsibilities.
It's much better to just like,
keep people voting for them
just based off of fear and anger
rather than like offering material solutions
to people's problems.
And so until the Republicans decide to like throw out,
you know, Ted Cruz out of Congress,
I don't know that that's ever-
Yeah, I mean, there was a sense in the immediate aftermath
that there was a coming to the senses
and some rationality being injected into the GOP
and perhaps this whole thing could be stabilized.
But as of late, most of the news is about Josh Holly
and about Marjorie Taylor Greene and Lauren Boebert,
and this extreme faction that, you know,
is a magnet for all the attention and press.
Yeah, I mean, I think it's ultimately gonna play out
on social media and we don't know,
kind of how that's gonna play out in part,
because there's been these mass bands and,
you know, the data scientists we talked to
in the course of making "Feels Good Man",
all sort of talk about how,
whenever there is a massive de-platforming,
there is some sort of reactionary response.
Don't know exactly what it is, but that is gonna happen.
There's a lot of people who I think,
feel a real sense of like loss without the ability
to hear from Trump constantly.
There is a weird vacuum.
There's a vacuum.
and I think that's happening in the left, too.
It's strange, even yeah,
like, just let him tweet for five minutes.
(guys chattering)
No, no, no.
The dog needs to hunt.
Yeah.
But there was that stat after Trump was de-platformed,
that there was a 70% drop in all of the hate speech
that surrounds all of this.
Oh, yeah.
Like, it was impactful for that alone.
It was a great move.
I mean, it should have happened before.
And then you have the migration to Parler
and everything that happened in Parler.
I think that it was more than just
for a couple of days.
A couple of significant things have happened, right?
So one is Twitter de-platformed all these people,
Parler got the plug pulled.
You know, they'll probably get back up at some point
if they're not yet, but at some point-
I think they're getting Russian money
or something like that, to be back up and running.
Are they back up and running now?
Not that I know of, but I didn't check today.
But then the corporate America stepped in
as like the moderator of the political world
after being the people that pumped the money in
and made it, kind of created these conditions.
All of a sudden, corporate America is like, well,
we're keeping track of who's saying what
and we're suspending our donations,
which is why I think McConnell was originally,
again, you know, very vocal, anti-Trump.
Why you had that change and Lynne Cheney speaking.
That had to be part of the consensus
or part of the math.
But I've always thought,
because the numbers are on the side of,
still, they are, the numbers are still on the side of people
who want to create a workable country.
They still are.
And we've had 6,000 people
in the last few weeks
leave the Republican party in North Carolina,
10,000 in Pennsylvania.
Now, if you've been watching these elections,
that's enough to swing an election.
Hmm hmm.
Yeah.
5,000 in Colorado, 5,000 in Arizona.
Those are concrete numbers,
they're reported by Colorado Public Radio, today.
I sent you that link.
Right.
We can link to it.
That's significant and all we've ever needed
is five to 10% of the leadership
in the Republican party and the Democratic party,
the rest of the Democratic party
to kind of agree on certain things
like to be able to deal with climate change
and loss of biodiversity and healthcare
and racial justice and criminal justice reform.
And that stuff's out there, like that's possible.
So it is possible that the radical right
have succeeded in creating a consensus
that never, that did not exist before.
It is possible that the breaking of the glass
is the breaking of the problem.
It is possible.
Now, we'll see, you know, like obviously,
that's admittedly a very optimistic viewpoint
on where things are going, but you know,
the Senate right now, you know, by the time this airs,
it may be old news, but today was kind of-
I can almost guarantee that it will be old news,
the way the-
But like, they're trying to work with Biden,
like there's five or 10 senators
who are trying to work with Biden on a plan
to deal with pandemic aid.
So there does seem to be, still possible,
the building of a consensus of people
who are not living in that alternate reality,
in that magical land, in that fever dream.
On the subject of de-platforming,
'cause I wanted to make this point.
I mean, I think de-platforming Trump was an easy call,
in light of everything,
and should have happened much earlier than it did.
So as late as it was,
I still applaud Jack and Twitter for taking that action.
But I also think that there is
an interesting conversation to be had
about the powers that are now held
by these gigantic tech conglomerates
and the stack that supports these platforms.
When AWS pulls the plug on Parler, we can applaud that
because Parler is such a shit show or whatever
but let's take a step back
and look at what that actually means.
And when that much power is vested in one organization,
it's not just the platform,
it's like these platforms need all of these other things
in order to exist.
How does that play out when there's a paradigm shift
in the powers that be?
Yeah.
Good question.
That's a very good point.
I think Facebook seems to be doing
a marketing move right now
where they're basically asking for regulation,
they're like welcoming it.
Like, we're ready to be regulated.
And it feels like they're just kicking the can down the road
because it's not something that they necessarily
want to instigate internally.
You know, I think it's also important to point out
that Parler wasn't sort of a passive take down.
It was actually a group of like first-generation hackers
who came in and basically,
showed all these security breaches,
caused a lot of havoc on the back end.
Like, they downloaded the entire app, right?
Everything that's every been posted, deleted posts,
are all now on a hard drive somewhere.
And that helped the FBI find a lot of these people, right?
And a lot of that group was like,
first-generation anonymous people-
The real, the hacker collective anonymous.
Wow, I didn't realize that.
Yeah, and in part, they were mad just
because Q anonymous was stealing their branding.
Right.
And.
So, it came from the internet before corporations came in
and did their due diligence.
Right, that's super interesting.
I didn't know that. (faint talking)
Tip the anonymous guys?
(men laughing)
Oh, shrug!
Oh, we have film, two.
(guys laughing and chattering)
No, but it's out there, too.
It's all out there in the public record
if you wanna look for it.
But, I do think that, you know,
Dorsey has been sort of acting like a moderator
but the reality is, I mean,
he made a lot of money off of Trump.
There was a lot of friction caused on his platform.
A lot of people spent time on it.
It's where QAnon really became
like a place of radicalization,
was on Twitter, as these drops would sort of come in
and speed along the agenda of Q.
I don't know, it seems like he needs to start acting
like a CEO and not like, you know,
I don't know.
Passive.
A passive moderator sitting on the beach,
waiting for his employees to come
and tell him to do something, which is what was happening.
It's also in terms of the broader conversation
and the ethical conversation about de-platforming,
it's also important, I think,
to understand that there's basically two cohorts
to the conversation.
They're just like the general user
who is maybe fearful for whatever reason
of losing their several hundred followers.
But then there's like the opportunist, right?
Like you have to be wary of the bad faith argument
that's often made during these conversations
by people like Alex Jones,
who wrap de-platforming in this First Amendment argument,
which is of course completely specious bullshit.
Because for them, it is an existential crisis for them.
If you are a grifter, like,
and I mentioned this in our last conversation,
but I think it bears mentioning,
like before the internet,
like you'd have to print pamphlets
and open up a fake church
and like really do the work to bring in people
into your flock and like convince them
to give you their money.
And then social media came out
and just basically like, if you wanna be a grifter,
it's like, it's a gold rush, right.
Not only is it easier to find people,
but people will put in their own bios, like,
please take my money.
Like, hashtag Q, you know, where are we going?
Where are go one, we go all,
like, you're basically advertising to the sheep,
I mean, as a sheep to the wolves,
like please take advantage of me.
And so like in these conversations about de-platforming,
the most vocal people are often the ones
who stand the most to gain
from like being able to be trolls online.
And the most lose,
should they be de-platformed?
Exactly.
Right.
So how do we, on this theme of like,
creating some kind of narrative through line from Peppe-
(guys chattering)
Tracking this through Q,
like now we have, you know, we've got Josh Hawley,
we've got Marjorie Taylor Greene, we got Lauren Boebert.
We got, you know, the Jewish space lasers
and now we have GameStop, right?
Like, is there like, have you forensically tracked
how we have gone in lock step through these various phases?
I mean, Peppe-
I mean.
GameStop seems the most similar
to the early days of Peppe.
Totally.
Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
Rating.
Like that's basically a big part of 4chan is about rating.
And like that's the most,
rating is basically the idea of like
getting all your online friends to go
and focus their energies on doing like one thing.
And affecting reality.
And Peppe, essentially,
all you have to really think about
in terms of Peppe's relationships to all of this
is that for a long time,
Peppe was just the icon for trolling,
the icon for that kind of duplicitous, online maneuvering,
Mischief making.
Mischief making, yeah.
Yeah, so.
But there's a glee in, you know,
that comes with this collective energy,
like, oh my God, we're all on the same page.
And we're gonna actually move culture
through our keystrokes.
Yes.
And that's so intoxicating.
Yeah.
Especially if you're, you know, in your mom's basement
and it's a pandemic and you know,
you're just on Robinhood or whatever, like, are you kidding?
Like, it's impossible if you're like a young male
to step away from the computer.
Well, and there's a real sense of,
back to the idea of alienation,
I mean, in some of the threads I've read for GameStop,
you know, there's still a simmering anger
from the housing crisis and the bailouts.
Yeah.
Right.
There's a lot of people who saw their parents
lose everything and never recover.
I mean, there's some really,
I'll send you guys some of the links,
but like there's some harrowing stories,
personal stories that people have posted on Reddit and stuff
about like, why they're all invested in this thing,
both literally and emotionally.
And like, the idea for them is like, look,
I've been poor my entire life.
I'll invest 300 bucks, even though I only have 600
because like, it's all, it doesn't make a difference to me.
It's more important for me to like,
use what little power I have collectively,
with my other friends to like,
screw over a bunch of-
Yeah, who cares?
It's not about making money.
Right.
It's about sticking it to the man.
And that's why they're able to hold the line
even when the stock price, you know,
is starting to fall and they're refusing to sell.
And the power of that is unbelievable.
And to kind of canvas, you know,
the reactions of the institutional investors
and the hedge funds,
I mean, the schadenfreude is delicious, of course,
because it's the people again, you know, it's like,
let them eat cake, no, you eat cake, you know?
And who's gonna,
it's a game of chicken and who's gonna blink first?
And you have this mob that's really,
I think you made a very good point, which is,
I think we're at a point culturally,
where the gap between the haves and the haves not
has reached such a point of division,
that it's inevitable that we're seeing these things happen.
And if you look back in history,
when that gap gets to a certain point,
that's when the government becomes destabilized
and you sow the seeds of this, you know,
this is a revolution in a certain respect
using tools that never existed before
to exert power against control.
That's gonna be the central struggle
for the Biden administration
is that he has to show the public
that government has a purpose
and it has to like,
people have to see material improvements in their lives
or else, we're all fucked.
Yeah.
Because of that gap, right?
'Cause the accelerationism is happening.
It's happening.
And I think it's also, you know,
talking about context, it's, you know,
we've experienced the COVID shutdowns
and the stock market has, in many cases, had gains.
You know, there's a lot of CEOs
that have made a tremendous amount of money.
People are aware of this now.
And then we're also dealing with,
people have a deeper literacy of cryptocurrency
on all of this online trading
and people no longer have a sense of reverence
for any of this stuff
because they don't see the way that it's affecting them.
You know, they're not sort of thinking about
their mutual funds in the basement.
They're just thinking about causing chaos
and then also hoping that this will improve
some sort of future,
that they recognize needs to happen.
They recognize a change needs to happen.
It's not just causing chaos though,
I mean, they're out to make money.
I mean, they're banding together, right,
so like just for your listener,
correct me if I'm wrong, I'll try it,
but just to recap it for listeners
that maybe haven't read all the GameStop already.
(guys chattering)
Just assuming everybody knows,
I don't know how you could know what this is but-
A little capsule.
You have a group of young investors using Reddit forums
and TikTok and they recruit and explain
these kind of mass mobilized stock purchases
and GameStop was one, AMC theaters, the other.
It turns out, it's all these-
Blockbuster.
Analog stocks.
It's like, instead of like,
you know, the Bushwick hipsters that would use a Blackberry,
these people are buying Blackberry stock
and doing it together.
But first, but obviously,
it was GameStop was the number one.
And the first guy-
It's out of nostalgia.
Out of nostalgia, but also as a, fuck you,
'cause it's strategic.
They see all these hedge funds
who are shorting specific stocks and they know-
It's the aggressiveness of the short positions
that these hedge funds were taking.
They had commandeered more shares
than were currently available.
Like I'm no expert.
I don't even know how that works.
But I think, if their short positions
hadn't been so aggressive,
this might not have ever happened.
But the "wallstreetbets" subreddit,
you know, made everybody aware of how egregious this was.
Right.
And marshaled all of these people
to take a stand against it.
And I think the other important point to make
is that the tools to flex your control over this
became so fluid,
that young people,
who weren't even old enough to get Robinhood accounts
could get them, not only get them,
but knew intuitively how to use them.
They're so easy to use right now.
And so those things coalesce to create a perfect storm
for this event to occur.
Yeah, I mean, I think the irony is,
from what I've read about how the GameStop thing started,
it really started like two years ago by one particular user
on this particular subreddit, "wallstreetbets",
but like, it was-
It was key, right.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
But it was rooted in fundamentals, right?
Like he noticed that they actually
had a lot of cash on hand.
They were undervalued.
Yeah.
And so it really starts from a pretty shrewd position
that came from what, you know,
this is the lie that Wall Street tells the public,
which is that they know best, right?
And here's a perfect example of someone
who doesn't have a huge institution behind him,
just does a lot of research and sees a hole in the market
and an opportunity and you know,
everyone else piles on, but it took him like two years-
But Michael Burry piled on, too,
like Michael Burry was early on this, as well.
He was saying the exact same thing.
He went all in on GameStop.
Like, I don't know how long ago, but quite a while ago.
But what's funny too, is that this is a return,
you know, it's worth pointing out
'cause we've kind of trashed 4chan for a while here.
When 4chan really got it in its heyday,
in its early days,
it really came from a more kind of a hacktivist position.
It was really during Occupy Wall Street
that it started doing its first big raids.
And there, you know, some of the first famous ones were
against like the Church of Scientology
and other sort of financial institution-based things.
But this is an interesting cultural turn back
towards what you might otherwise call like a kind of
collectivist perspective on like how rates can benefit.
Well, and the things that they're trading are,
you know, GameStop is something that people love.
Yeah.
Like it is nostalgia.
And it's like, people have gotten rich off of their passion.
And therefore,
there's some just desserts that are happening.
Oh, and your guy, that you're talking about,
the guy that started it,
invested like 50 something thousand dollars
and topped out at over 40 million
at one point, he claimed.
And who knows what?
But like, but it's also a police operation, right?
Policing these hedge funds.
Now that hedge funds are gonna have to watch.
Right.
And wash their hands.
But now they're hiring their own meme departments.
So there's a counter veiling war for-
That's amazing.
Yeah.
In the attention economy, right?
So they're hiring a bunch of young people
who are gonna create their own memes
that are gonna contravene the memes
that are coming out of "wallstreetbets".
And there's gonna be a war of ideas afoot.
But essentially, when you step back from this
and look at it,
what's to stop this community of people from,
every week, just deciding, okay, here's what,
we're all gonna buy this today.
And then millions of people like buy this stuff.
Like, they could just repetitively do this at will
and commandeer the entire market.
Its hard though, I mean, like ask Michael Bloomberg
because he spent a lot of money creating memes
and it got him nowhere. (laughing)
Or ask us, we're trying to sell our film
to the same community of people
and as best as we can, it's hard
to like get a huge movement but you know, the truth is-
It's hard go viral.
It's hard to go viral.
That's the point, yeah.
No, but this is a lightening in the bottle moment
where I think people are daunting,
like people are having a system awareness
they weren't aware of before
and they realize how easy it is to game these systems.
And there's more people willing to sort of be part of that.
I think it's also just generational.
There's a younger generation who is really enjoying this,
that doesn't feel secure in their future.
And how are they gonna find meaning in America?
Yeah, it's a super important point.
Yeah, the grand narratives of America are going away
and we have to figure out new narratives
that we can all latch on to, to find meaning in our lives.
But the problem is you have these two,
now there's two dueling stunk projects.
Right?
Right, yeah.
Ben Mezrich and the-
So, this is so, I mean on the subject of like,
just the velocity of the news cycle,
like Ben Mezrich hasn't even like,
all he has is a book proposal on GameStop.
Right.
There's no book, yet.
He sells the book and the movie rights, get picked up
by essentially the same team that made-
The social.
"The Social Network".
With the exception of Fincher.
He's got like the same producing team,
the Winklevoss involved.
(men laughing)
No, the Winklevoss are involved in this project, yeah.
Because Mezrich also wrote a book about Bitcoin
where those two guys are like the starring-
Right, right, right.
Feature in that.
At the same time, Netflix just announced
another GameStop movie project, as well.
Right?
Right.
So the reason that is important though, is that like,
you know, it's gonna be,
these movies are gonna be like, look at the little guy,
got rich at the expense of the big guy.
And we're telling the same story in America.
And the story is the answer to your problems is money
and listen, for someone who's been broke
a lot of his adult life and just scraping by,
but like, and now has made some money,
money doesn't buy happiness, it's buy happier, it's true.
But like, the idea that we need to recalibrate who we are
and how we function,
I think goes that deep.
Like we really need to start to ask important questions
about, like meaning of life shit,
because otherwise, this stuff is gonna keep happening.
The cycles are just gonna keep going.
But it's more complicated than the money.
So much of this is just the, fuck you, to the man.
Right.
Against a system that has overlooked these people
and not given them the opportunities
that they feel that they've been promised and so-
Right, the American dream entitlement.
Yeah, it's like, you know,
the guy who's not worried about losing his 300 bucks,
even though he doesn't have any money
because of the point that's being made is more important.
And that's the sense of emotional connection to a movement
and the community aspect of this that's so powerful.
But if the story is like,
the answer is we, you know, fuck you
and we made some of your money,
which hopefully, the movies are more complex than that.
But like, 'cause we don't know how it ends.
Right.
But some of these people are gonna lose all their money
and it won't just go back to the beginning.
But like you're saying,
you need to see some tangible,
like government has to improve people's lives.
There has to be some tangible change
in the way we relate to each other
and in the way government is viewed.
Because a lot of what you're saying,
like this entitlement is like, I'm getting screwed,
some of that is just a story you're telling yourself.
It's not all true, you know?
Like there are opportunities here in this country
to do better.
It is hard.
And the rich are getting richer, it's true.
But there is opportunity out there every day you wake up
and we all know that.
And so, not all of those things are true,
but that doesn't mean that people aren't embittered.
And so there's this,
especially when you look at the rotunda,
people who show up, like that real estate woman
who showed up in a private jet,
there are people who are,
I know people who have done very well
and are still embittered,
so embittered that they think "The 1619 Project"
is somehow a personal affront to them,
like just crazy shit.
Like, that doesn't make any sense.
There's a bitterness level to this
that is hard to kind of quantify.
And then you have people like Holly that you brought up
who's trying to ride that basically to the presidency,
or you have these other, you know,
Marjorie Taylor Greene and Lauren Boebert,
who are just riding the wave
because maybe they're part of the wave, you know,
calling for the assassination of the Speaker of the House
and that person is now sitting in Congress.
Like there's a bitterness level that's just really,
we haven't quite figured out yet, right?
Like, where it's coming from and how to fix it.
But I think there's fundamental questions
in this country that need to be answered.
And you know, this is a nice story,
but like, to fix it,
in order for Wall Street to be safe,
in order for all of us to be safe,
in order for people to feel good in their own neighborhoods,
we've gotta fix this stuff.
Yeah.
The through line there, the thing that connects QAnon
and the "wallstreetbets" GameStop thing
is that it's two groups of people
who are experiencing a kind of like,
I dunno, rejection of the American dream,
but for two completely different reasons.
Like the QAnon people have had to confront a reality
that like, the truth about America,
American exceptionalism has kind of eroded around them.
Whether it's like the BLM protest this last summer,
or just the fact that the internet exists now,
and that you were exposed to information
that you maybe were hidden from for years before
and now you're having to like confront this reality.
And there's a certain level of,
what's the term I'm looking for here?
I'm not sure. (laughing)
Like intellectual, what's this?
Cognitive dissonance.
Cognitive dissonance!
There's a cognitive dissonance that's happening.
And they wanna maintain that perception
of American exceptionalism.
And so Q very neatly gives them that,
that they're on the side of good
and the other people are evil.
And then with the GameStop people,
it's similarly
a rejection of the American dream
or feeling that like, it's not there for them.
And they're like using their collective energies
to like impact in ways that they think
will help ameliorate the problems.
So they're both kind of, pretty directly connected.
I think it dovetails also,
with just the religious nature of America.
We've always been obsessed with apocalypse,
even people who aren't necessarily religious have just-
Yeah.
That's become part of who they are and their thinking.
You know, for all of these people, we've talked about,
you know, they believe we're living in the end times.
Josh Holly believes that we are living in Babylon.
It's something where he thinks that, you know,
the rapture is upon us.
There's a lot of people out there
who are just hardwired to think that there is no future
because they can't conceive of it.
And I think that sometimes even understanding that
is part of the problem.
You have like, we were talking about
like the "GameStop" movie,
like I'm sure the end of that movie will be
kind of like an anti-corporate idea.
Right.
At the end of it.
But it's being made by a corporation
who's making money off of that.
So this awareness of the futility
is only making us more bitter.
Right?
Yeah, you know.
It's in a circle to drain more.
Ultimately, the way this is gonna shake out
is like any casino where the house wins.
Yep.
Like, okay.
"Wallstreetbets" upended these hedge funds.
But at some point, there's gonna be a recalibration
where these hedge funds are gonna come out on top,
if history tells us anything,
whether through regulatory measures or what have you,
something's gonna occur that is gonna prevent
this thing from happening again.
That's only gonna fuel like that level of frustration
and discontent.
Poor, Elon.
In terms of the house winning,
like BlackRock owned a significant chunk
of GameStop before this.
And they made something like $3 billion out of spike.
So like they're making-
And you, also, we should point out,
you made a good point on Twitter the other day, Giorgio.
It would be terrible and disheartening.
Like we need to know more about
who's invested in these hedge funds
that took these short positions
because, you know, chances are,
there are pension funds and teacher's union funds
and things like that.
People's retirement is tied up in these massive hedge funds.
And when those short positions tank
and those people lose all their money,
those are the very people that are, you know,
the same community,
it's like the parents of the "wallstreetbets" people
are losing their retirement funds as a result of this.
It wouldn't be the first time,
if that ends up happening, it wouldn't be the first time
that 4chan raid has gone, backfired. (laughing)
Here's a question for you.
We were talking about this, Adam.
Yep.
In this conversation around the regulation
of these social media platforms or how to deal with speech,
it seems like Reddit has gotten somewhat of a pass here.
And there is the conventional wisdom is that
Reddit has done a better job than Facebook and Twitter.
I don't know enough about it to know if that's true or not.
But what do you-
Yeah, no one's criticizing Reddit on television.
Yeah, they've had a,
I mean, so, when Ellen Powell was the CEO,
I tried to get her to be part of the film,
but she politely declined,
but I would've really loved to talk to her about this,
but, you know, she was removed as CEO
during the midst of the Gamergate thing.
And I think in hindsight,
that was probably a really bad move.
And I think they had been like living with,
I mean as the board, I guess,
they had been living with that guilt
of that mistake probably.
And I think they've taken pretty proactive attempts
at like, you know, they took down "The_Donald".
Moderation just operates a lot differently there.
I'm by no means an expert, but for sure,
they have definitely skirted a lot of blame
but they also took down the "wallstreetbets" thing,
quite quickly.
Well, they did it, they made it private, right?
Yeah.
And then it went public again.
But I think they pulled that.
And now, it's back the way it was.
It was private for a while.
When the trading volume was insane,
they made it private for a minute.
Yeah, I mean, I'm not an expert on it either.
I think that they always try to like,
when they pull down like "The_Donald",
they pulled down several lefty kind of boards
at the same time.
Both sides.
So they try to give people the illusion of parody
which I think ultimately is probably good,
but I don't think radicalization happens on Reddit
the same way it happens in Facebook or in Twitter.
I think, also, I mean, taking Parler down,
all these sort of things are cursory moves, but you know,
everyone uses multiple platforms.
And the problems still remain on Twitter and Facebook.
And those are the places where people, I think,
really lose themselves, so.
Yeah.
It's also like,
understanding the nature of their mechanics, right?
On Reddit, things get upvoted and downvoted,
so there's kind of a consensus there
that's much different than for example, the way 4chan works,
which things float to the top
just simply by virtue of the engagement.
So in 4chan, if you just post something really incendiary
and get a lot of posts, replies to it,
it'll move to the top.
So those are, it's like kind of nuanced,
but it produces much different thinking.
I think Reddit is more of an entertainment site
whereas these other are more lifestyle sites.
How interesting.
You know, so if you're on Facebook,
the way that radicalization will often happen on Facebook
is you have these sort of extreme ideas
coming into places that are not extreme.
You have people liking and sharing this stuff
and then ultimately, normalizing it in the same feed
that they're sharing pictures of their grandkids,
or, you know, memes about Bible verses or whatnot.
And Reddit, the flow of information isn't quite so chaotic.
You're going there for specific reasons,
to be part of a specific community.
Facebook though, you really kind of end up absorbing
these ideas in what seems to be a relatively organic way.
They're fed to you.
Yes, they're fed to you.
And so, yeah, we have this problem right now
where there's just a lot of toxic waste in the system
and it's mutating people.
I don't know how-
(men laughing)
I mean, you do have a lot of zombies out there.
Yeah, totally.
(men chattering)
Absolutely.
But it's hard to, you know, on 4chan,
as it related to Peppe,
like the big thing that people will say
when they haven't seen "Feels Good Man", yet,
is that like Peppe isn't a hate symbol.
You took the bait, your normy.
Right, there was some YouTube comments on our podcasts.
(men chattering)
Yeah, like a bunch of those guys.
And I was like,
did you watch the podcast?
But it's like that, Peppe represented a way to like,
what we call, Arthur referred to it earlier,
as like being irony poisoned,
that there's a moment at which you can't tell
what is a joke and what is real.
And for a lot of new users of social media in general,
older audiences, it's even harder for them
to discern what's new or what's real, or what's a joke.
And it just like reminded me,
I was trying to find the article before we came today.
But I remember when Nicole Borowitz went off the air
and there was an article in like, "The New Yorker"
or something about it.
And they said that something like,
some astonishingly high number of regular viewers
of the show did not discern that it was satire.
Like 20% of the regular audience didn't understand that.
Get out.
Couldn't understand that Borowitz was doing a bit.
And so I think about that-
We should have known then.
Wow.
(men laughing)
We should all move to Sydney.
Yeah.
Exactly.
(men laughing)
So anyway, I would love to.
I'm pretty sure I'm not making that up.
One issue before you wrap it, Rich,
was Peppe in the rotunda?
Yeah.
Yeah, but not as much as you would have thought maybe.
Well, I mean, there were a handful of people there
wearing Peppe masks and then there were some Peppe signs.
But I mean, it is interesting to see-
They were older people.
Hmm, some of the people in masks were younger,
though it was interesting to see like
at the rally in Georgia,
before the election, there,
there was a number of people who were wearing
like Peppe stuff, like there was a guy wearing a Peppe shirt
but he was an older guy.
He was like 65.
And all the people who were commenting on it,
underneath the posting,
were all like older women who were like Peppe, Peppe.
So, the generational shift is apparent in that moment.
I mean, obviously memes played a huge part
in the rotunda riot.
You saw the Kekistan flag,
you saw all this different stuff.
And people were often, you know,
a lot of the Proud Boys were wearing anti-Semitic,
you know, the Holocaust didn't happen,
you know, six million is not enough kind of memes.
It was a very memed thing,
in part, because I think people really wanted
to participate in it through social media
and this was a way to do it.
And then obviously, to find each other in the crowd
because it was so chaotic.
Yeah.
Despite the presence of Peppe, though,
it does feel like culture's kind of moved on.
Like, it-
For sure.
It wasn't omnipresent in that, at all.
Like it was kind of there,
but the sense that I got was like,
okay, we're on to other things now.
Peppe's played out.
Yeah, it's played out.
For sure.
Peppe's a much, there's a much bigger relationship
like positive relationship people have to Peppe,
for example, on Twitch.
It's like the number one,
if you look at a list
of the a hundred most used emotes on Twitch,
Peppe occupies like 50 of the top 100.
And they all are like back to the original Peppe version
of just being a funny reaction image.
Hey, Matt's getting a fish.
Yeah, that's true.
But I'm still trying to wrap my head
around wearing a Holocaust denial merch
to just stand out in a crowd, so your buddy can see you.
Yeah, I'm over, I'm at 4H.
I'm wearing, you know,
the six million is not enough, t-shirt.
I'm the only guy.
Yeah.
There's a big space around me.
It's okay folks, I'm Jewish.
Be careful though,
because a laser might get you from space.
Oh my God, like, can we talk about,
is she the dumbest Congress person of our lifetime?
I will say-
Top five?
Denver Riggleman, the former Republican Congressman,
who we've shot a little bit with last year,
he's gotten into it quite a bit with her online
but he made a very like simple point to make,
which was just that the starting salary for a congressperson
or the salary for a congressperson
is like $165,000 or something.
He's like, that's more money than most people
have ever seen or will ever see and like-
Yeah, we're overpaying for her.
What you're seeing is the
enmeshing basically, of like,
social media personalities and government.
And it's like, if you're gonna be a grifter,
it's never been a better time to be in government
as a grifter, basically.
'Cause you also can raise money.
Exactly.
On that.
Like, wasn't it disclosed that Trump made,
like raised how many million dollars?
31.
Was it?
Oh, well in a two weeks after the election.
Yeah.
200 something million dollars?
Yes.
Yeah.
And he spent zero on the,
it was all under the,
well, the one I read was like 31 or $32 million
specifically on emails that were about Senate in Georgia.
And he spends literally $0.
Yeah, 'cause there was like a,
I can't wait for the-
By the way, we don't have to spend this on this.
Exactly.
We can keep it.
Yeah, I don't know if she's the dumbest or not,
but she might be.
I mean, it's pretty astounding.
It's pretty bad.
Like, Boebert and her are wild.
Yeah, they're basically just assemblages of memes.
I mean, even when you hear them talk.
They can't speak.
Yeah!
It's like a regurgitation of internet gab.
Which is why I think Holly is worse
because I didn't know that about Holly's feeling
about living in Babylon.
Like I think, I was reading, you know,
the reporting on Holly is that he was thought of
as this star and really an intellectual giant
and the fact that he is like, you know,
it's great to see him disavowed by his mentor
who doesn't have to run for-
Danforth?
Yeah, but like the way he's saying,
it's the biggest mistake of his entire life.
And that carries water, like, I'm from Missouri.
And so Danforth is definitely a very powerful
and well-loved politician in Missouri.
I'm curious to see what Holly's future is in the state,
in part, because Missouri has often been a bellwether,
you know, people like, you know,
Roy Blunt and John Ashcroft and these sort of people
have come out of Missouri and then come
into the international stage and had a lot of power.
Yeah, Holly is an ideolog.
Unlike Boebert and Marjorie Taylor Greene,
he has like a very specific ideological framework
that he talks about.
You know, he talks about it in Christian media,
more so than in national media.
But yeah, he's someone who like,
a lot of the insurrections have given up on democracy.
It was a coalition of people who have given up on democracy
and he's one of them.
He doesn't believe that freedom can exist
in a civil society
because we're not all Christian evangelical.
He just wants power.
Yeah, completely.
And it's frightening because he-
Yeah, he thinks it comes from Jesus Christ.
And he's not a dummy, you know,
that political article was very revealing.
It interviewed a bunch of his professors at Stanford
and David Kennedy, who's a professor that I had at Stanford.
Like I know David Kennedy,
said that Josh was the most talented student
that he ever had, you know.
And like, this is a guy who's bright.
His ideas might not align with yours
but he should not be underestimated.
And he cannot be lumped in
with the Boebert's and the Taylor Greene's
He's a different animal, altogether.
And when he was 15,
he wrote in his Lexington newspaper,
the Lexington, Missouri newspaper,
in defense of the militia after the Oklahoma City bombing.
And just saying that militia people
who are in militia shouldn't be maligned as racist.
They shouldn't be called terrorists, as a 15-year-old.
So, you know, so even though-
It's not opportunist in his idealog.
I think he is an opportunist, to your professor-
Well but it's inbreded.
He's not a Johnny-come-lately, to these ideas
because it's opportunistic to be that way.
This is the person that he's been.
I'm curious though because-
And he's just been masking it, in different company.
He comes across as such an egg head.
I think there's a part of Republican politics
that doesn't necessarily like the Ivy league education.
Right.
You know, I'm curious to see,
I think him, you know, sort of coming out,
basically in support of the insurrection,
was him trying to seem alpha,
was him trying to sort of play Trump's game,
to Trump's audience.
Right.
And I think they're gonna see through it.
I think they're gonna realize that-
In the way they see through Ted Cruz.
Hmm hmm.
Maybe.
But you know, here's the thing, is that like,
so I gave you my optimistic view
on how this is gonna work out well, for us.
Come on man, we gotta land this.
(guys chattering)
We've gotta go hardcore.
(guys chattering and laughing)
With "Babylon Berlin".
And that is, like people were talking about Kristallnacht
as like the Nazi equivalent of what happened
at the rotunda but that's not what it was.
It was the Putsch.
I don't know how to pronounce it right.
But in 1929 or 30, I forget when it was,
when Hitler's first attempt to take over government.
He had a mob like this and he was arrested
and he was put in jail
and he was eventually pardoned and came out of it
and ended up, you know.
We all know where that went.
So the question really is, you know, it's easy,
I also, my instinct is that anyone who tries
to play Trump's game is gonna lose
'cause only Trump can play it.
And I think Holly will lose.
But there is like, if there's any one of those people
that scares me, it's him.
And we won't know what happens, like you said,
like there's a 10 year timeline
to where this is going
and hopefully, we'll come out of it.
I think we can come out of it.
I think we've mapped out how we'll come out of it.
But there are multiple realities.
So, we'll see.
Hmm hmm.
And if we know anything, we know by next week,
everything will be, something else crazy will happen
and we'll be having a different conversation.
In the meantime, watch this movie.
Thank you.
Yeah.
(guys chattering)
I love that you're wearing the shirt.
That's amazing, yeah, thank you.
I love having you guys here.
That was super fun.
Please, everybody who's listening or watching,
go out, check out, "Feels Good Man" on Apple+, preferably.
It's a fantastic documentary.
If you have not listened to the podcast
that I did with these gentlemen, a couple of weeks ago,
check that out.
I'll link that up in the show notes
and in the description below.
How's it going with the movie, before we end it here?
It's Oscar weeks.
People are voting.
If you're a voter, watch the film.
You've got to get attention on this movie.
Yeah.
We're a dark horse.
Yeah, we're definitely a dark horse.
I was gonna say, but it's going great.
We did a big Twitch live stream, actually,
with a number of gamers.
Lots of Academy voters on Twitter.
Exactly.
You know, no Academy voters.
But Fury was on the line with us and it was great.
It was a very like positive,
interesting engaged conversation.
We continue to meet people
who the film means something to them, yeah.
It's a long tail film.
It's a long tail film that and yeah,
it's something we've been so passionate about.
It's great to see it out in the world
and people responding to it.
Yeah, I mean the best document of the year
is definitely "Time" on Amazon,
which you should definitely watch.
So by no means, do we think we have a chance in hell
of a winning anything,
but it would be nice to just get shortlisted.
Let's get your shortlisted.
I saw "Time".
I liked your movie better.
Wow.
And I like "Time", I liked "Time".
It's just really fascinating that they made that movie.
That was one, if there was a movie theater,
that's one that really, breaks my heart, there wasn't.
That was the last film we saw at Sundance last year.
And it's like (sighs).
It's a beautiful movie.
And Sundance is going on right now.
Are you guys doing any panels
or do you have any involvement with that?
No, but our producers who worked on
"Feels Good Man", with us, have a couple of films there.
They have a film named "Cusp".
"Cusp", yeah.
That I haven't seen but I'm excited to see it
and yeah, it is too bad it's all online.
Yeah.
I mean-
It's such a fun experience to go there and just.
Have you seen their virtual waiting room thing?
No.
Oh, that's really dystopic.
(men laughing)
Is it really?
Yeah.
Man, it's such a fun in-person event.
Like I just can't imagine the virtual version of it.
Well, hopefully that's how the world will change
between this podcast being recorded
and put out in the world-
It will help.
It will help if people can hang out.
A hundred percent.
That's true.
It will help. (laughing)
A hundred percent.
Absolutely, absolutely.
If the kids can go back to school.
That's the title of this podcast.
I just have the title of the episode now.
We don't do well on our own.
Not loose ends.
Yeah, in a weird way,
the anti-maskers are really just people
that are just dying for a hug.
That's really all they want at the end of the day.
They just can't deal with.
That's right, that's right.
There was a, I think it was either an "Onion" article
or some other kind of
satire piece on the internet that said,
"Proud Boy Gets Turned With One Hug From Dad" or something.
It was hard times, hardtimes.com.
(men laughing)
It's true.
See, "Feels Good Man".
Thanks for coming on, you guys.
Thank you so much.
Come back anytime.
Let's continue this conversation.
Thanks for having us.
All right.
Yeah.
It's been gold.
And let's all go hardcore happy.
Hardcore happy.
Well, you brought your, you have a guest coming up
that can teach us how to be,
how to connect with each other, right?
We do, yeah.
We'll talk about that after the break.
All right, cool.
Cool.
So we'll take a break.
We'll be back with more.
(air whooshing)
All right, and we're back.
I love those guys.
That was great.
Aw, man, hot.
I thought it might be like 30 to 40 minutes.
How long did we go?
Like an hour, right?
There's no way I was gonna interrupt.
It was too good.
Time stops when I'm with you Rich,
especially when I'm talking.
(men laughing)
So this is gonna be yet another marathon "Roll On", right?
Yes, yes.
But I think we, during the break,
we decided to eviscerate the outline a little bit
to not make it too long
but I do wanna do a little bit of show and tell,
a couple of wins of the week.
And we'll get to three listener questions
and at the top of my list of show and tells,
I've got two things.
The first thing is,
and this is nothing new, but I just felt like,
amidst all the darkness,
we could all use a little bit of innocent happiness.
Yes.
And I wanted to draw a little bit of attention
to David Lynch's, wonderful weather reports.
Are you familiar with this?
I am, I am,
'cause I listened to KCRW
and so he pops up on "Morning Becomes Eclectic".
Does he do the weather report on their weather on video?
Yeah, he's their weather guy.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I dunno when he started doing this,
but on YouTube every single day,
he just looks to camera and he says, good morning,
today is whatever it is.
And then he looks out the window
and he tells you what the weather is gonna be.
And it's just the best.
He looks great.
I love it.
You know, there's a shortlist of people
that can stay cool for like four decades.
He's the coolest.
Bowie and David Lynch,
there's only a few people, Prince, there's only a few.
And my son, Tyler and Trapper, just love David Lynch.
They just can't get enough of him.
And how old is he now?
He's in his seventies, right?
Yeah, that's what I mean.
And he's still the coolest guy in the room.
Right.
No matter what.
He is.
And all he does is say,
this is what the weather is gonna be like today.
And I don't know what it is about his energy,
but I'm always glad that I watch it.
Yeah, he's happy.
He's a happy, like he makes you feel happier.
I know!
Yeah.
It's great and we all need more of that.
It was trending on Twitter, I think today,
because he announced that he was thinking about
not doing it anymore and all the fans revolted.
And so his big announcement was that
he would continue with his weather reports.
He's gonna keep doing it.
Supplemented with also, I don't know if you know this.
He also does the number of the day.
Yes, but not everyone has a number of the day.
Right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that like a, does he play the numbers?
No, he just basically says, the number of the day is
and he just says the number.
Okay.
And that's the number of the day,
according to David Lynch.
I wonder if like his parents played the numbers
back in New York or something.
I think you're attributing too much
of forethought to all of this.
I'm reading too deep into it. (laughing)
Yeah, just take it for what it is.
I would say a second cousin to this is Anthony Hopkin's
little videos that he posts on Instagram.
I haven't seen those.
They're always full of love and happiness.
Really?
Hmm hmm?
Yeah.
You mean, Hannibal Lecter?
Yeah, he's great.
Full of love and happiness?
Anthony Hopkins, not to be confused with Hannibal Lecter.
All right, let's keep it moving.
You mentioned earlier, "Babylon Berlin".
Yes.
Which is a TV show that I wanted to share
with all of you guys that I've been enjoying.
It's a German series, that's airing on Netflix.
It was created by writer, director, Tom Tykwer,
who is the guy behind "Run Lola Run" and also "Cloud Atlas".
And I find this show, I mean,
I'm like near the end of season two,
there's three seasons currently available
that are streaming right now.
And I find this show to be really fascinating
for a number of reasons.
First of all, it's exceptionally photographed,
like it's visually arresting and stunning.
And essentially, it's a story,
it's multiple stories that take place in Berlin,
post-World World War I,
in the midst of this newly emerged Weimar Republic
where it's a new democracy but it's a fragile democracy.
And we see this extraordinary wealth disparity.
On the one hand, you have this roaring twenties culture
of nightclubs and fabulous music and dancing
and drinking and revelry,
juxtaposed against extreme poverty
and the storylines elucidate
the fragility of democratic institutions.
It's about corruption.
And it's about the nationalistic creep
that ultimately later leads to Nazi-ism
through the lens of the protagonist
who is this police investigator
and all the kind of people that he encounters.
And a World War I veteran.
Yeah, World War I veteran and so there's a lot of,
you know, guys with disfigured faces and maimed
and he, this protagonist, you know,
also has these, essentially,
PTSD panic attacks where he has to down
some unknown pharmaceutical,
that I assume is like morphine or something like that.
He just goes into these these shaking fits
and I don't know, I just think it's
standing in and of itself,
it's a fascinating look into a particular culture
but I think it also
is prescient and relevant to some of the things
that our culture is grappling with right now,
the fragility of our own democratic institutions
and the nationalistic creep that you see
when that wealth gap becomes as extreme
as it did in Germany, at that time
and as it's quickly becoming in our country.
Great movie, I mean, great show.
Thank you for recommending it.
I just saw the pilot last night
and "Run Lola Run" was one of my favorites when it came out.
It was great.
And so I was really excited about it.
It's really good.
I'm into it.
And the best part is that through that show,
I finally figured out how to get to subtitles
in prestige foreign television on Netflix,
because before, it was always these horrible dub things
and I couldn't get through one episode.
Well, you could just select audio
and then it gives you all these options.
Hey, I did it.
It's interesting.
I'm saying, I did it.
That you opt for subtitles.
I do.
And I opted for the dubbing.
You like the dubbing?
I don't wanna read, when I'm watching.
Yeah.
But here's the thing.
The dubbing, of course, it's jarring.
I can't watch them mixed matched.
I can't do that, I can't.
It doesn't quite work, but at some point,
you just get over it and you just go with it.
And the acting is not as good.
It's not as good a voice.
Yeah, yeah.
And then, if you go back to just the subtitles,
when you've gotten used to the dub voice,
and then you hear what their voice actually like,
that's also very jarring.
Yes.
But, anyway.
But, anyway, I think that the reason it's important,
what you're saying is, that even today,
there's no country that really mirrors
what we're going through better than Germany.
Not because it's as diverse as we are
or has exactly the same problems,
but there is this far right, QAnon worshiping,
kind of militia, like white supremacist element
that has infiltrated into politics
and into even police departments
and the military itself,
shut down an entire special forces unit.
That stuff's all been really well reported
by the "New York Times".
I think we've even maybe touched on it once.
And so, they're going through the same thing we are.
So it's interesting that he's using the 1920s
'cause when it really first started,
you know, the cycle.
Right.
That same stuff was happening here.
We're familiar, it's a period of time in Germany
that I'm just not that familiar with.
Right, but-
Like, we know about World War I
and we know about World War II,
but what happened in between those
that led to the rise of Hitler?
Right, but that same kind of Proto-fascism,
like leading towards fascism,
that lean, the tear between socialism
and what was gonna become fascism,
those same threads,
those same currents are running through America
at the same time.
Right.
When you had the Limburg candidacy
and all of that.
So all of that stuff was happening,
we've been mirrors of each other for a long, long time.
So it's really interesting to watch it now.
'Cause it's still entertaining 'cause it does transport you.
You're not thinking about our problems
when you're watching it, but it is,
it does give it like that relevance.
Yeah and what's great is there's three seasons of it.
So I can be enjoying this for quite awhile.
Exactly.
Cool.
Why don't you hit me with your win of the week?
My win of week was the K2 climbers,
the the Nepalese team of nine climbers
that got up to the top of K2 in winter
for the very first time.
It was the last of the 8,000 meter peaks
to be climbed in winter.
They've all now been conquered
in spring, summer or winter.
K2 has by far the highest mortality rate
on its slopes compared to any of the others.
It's night and days, more dangerous than even Everest.
And so it was just,
I did that story for the "New York Times" when it happened.
I was turned on to the story
because I knew Colin O'Brady was among
the many climbers that went out.
Right, he's still like at base camp, right?
He's still at base camp.
He's been at base camp for months.
Yeah and so he was one of that, part of that group.
That's how I first got turned on to the fact
that people were trying for this.
And then, one of the people who I knew about,
well, that he told me about was Nimsdai or Nims Purja,
who is the guy that set the record,
world record for climbing all the 8,000 meter peaks
within a certain amount of time.
And he shaved over seven years off the record.
Wow.
And so, Nims Purja is this great Nepalese climber,
former British special forces and all these other,
and he's not Sherpa, he's not from the Sherpa culture
but everybody else was, that was in that group.
And so this story is about how they got up to the top
and how that all happened and was cool.
They were greeted back in Katmandu recently
with a hero's welcome, like a big motorcade.
They've been treated like celebrities.
They're the toast of the town.
They were flown out from base camp
by the Pakistani military
and got an audience with the prime minister
or the president of Pakistan like right away.
It did become a big story.
It's a big deal.
It's super cool.
It's a big deal because what's cool is,
all of the 8,000 meter peaks in Nepal were all credit,
even though there were,
there was always an Nepalese climber
right behind whoever got the credit,
it was always the European or Western climber
that got the first ascent, that's who got credited.
So, this is basically a correction for that.
Yeah, it's very cool.
Yeah.
So everybody check out Adam's article
in the "New York Times".
It's called, "How Climbers Reached the Summit of K2
"in Winter for the First Time".
You've got comments from "Run On", Jimmy Chin,
Adrian Ballinger, all kinds of cool people.
Yeah, hat tip to Rich Roll to get Jimmy Chin
to connect.
I did not do-
Yeah, you did, you did.
But you're the journalist here, man.
Yeah, You did.
Good stuff, dude.
Thank you.
Well, my win of the week, hands down,
goes to Jim Walmsley,
who is an Ultra runner extraordinaire,
guy lives in Arizona, for those who aren't familiar,
who just the other week,
attempted to break the World Record in the 100K
at this event called the HOKA Onay,
Project Carbon X event that was in Chandler, Arizona.
He ran a hundred kilometers in six hours,
nine minutes and 26 seconds.
And ultimately, came up just 12 seconds shy
of the World Record, which was set in 2018,
by Japan's Nao Khuzami.
That's crazy.
I'm not pronouncing that correctly.
But he did set an American record by 18 minutes
and a PR of 45 minutes.
So this is insane, just so people can grok exactly
how extraordinary this is,
he ran 5:56 pace for over six hours straight.
And he clipped a fence at about three and a half hours
into this thing and his shoulder was bleeding.
Like, it's bananas.
And in and of itself,
this is an unbelievable accomplishment.
But when you set it in the context of this guy's career,
it's really noteworthy because what's unique about Jim
is that he excels, not just in Ultrarunning,
but in many distances across many terrains.
He's won a ton of Ultras, of course.
He was the victor in the 2018
and the 2019 Western States 100,
which is kind of widely considered one of,
if not the most prestigious UltraRunning Race in the world.
He set the course record in 2018
and then he broke it again in 2019,
by 21 minutes.
Crazy.
But he also qualified for the Olympic trials
in the marathon by running a 64-minute half marathon
and then running a 2:15 marathon at the Olympic trials.
So this is a guy who can kill it on the road.
He can kill it at the half marathon.
He can go a hundred miles and then some.
So was he set to compete in the Olympics?
No, I mean, he ran the Olympic trial.
He did, he ran 2:15.
So he wasn't gonna make the Olympic team with that.
But for a guy who,
it's unusual for somebody who
specializes in Ultras or a hundred mile races
to be a decent marathon.
Right.
Usually you go slow, right?
By comparison, the marathon is like,
the level of speed that you have to run the marathon in
to be at the elite level
is a completely different pursuit
than running a 100 mile trail race at altitude.
Have you ever run just a marathon?
Like not-
I have, yeah.
No, I have.
I ran the Long Beach Marathon,
before I did any of the UltraMans
and it was not a good experience.
(Adam laughing)
But it was before I knew what I was doing, but I'm not,
I would never be good at that.
I'm not a fast runner, you know, I'm a tortoise.
I was just curious if you've ever done it,
like done the New York,
I could see wanting to do the New York Marathon.
Maybe, at some point.
Yeah.
We'll see.
Here's an interesting fact about Jim before we move on.
He went to the Air Force Academy
and worked as a missileer in Montana,
working underground on nuclear weapons at 24 hour shifts.
So he's also, you gotta,
I would suspect you gotta be a pretty smart dude.
You do, but see, this is always curious to me
about people who have dangerous jobs.
They shouldn't have 24 hour shifts.
I agree, that, I agree with.
Like, why do surgeons have-
Well, the article that I read this in,
it just put the 24 hour thing at the end of the sentence,
but it doesn't make sense.
Doctors, like why?
I don't want my nuclear weapons guy,
to not get eight hours of sleep.
(Adam laughing)
I'd agree with that.
I'd agree with that, all right.
Let's do some listener questions.
Okay.
We didn't get to the Adam Grant book, by the way.
Do you wanna get to that?
Oh, yeah.
And show and tell?
So, today's Monday.
On Wednesday, I'm interviewing Adam Grant for the podcast.
For those that don't know,
he is a organizational psychologist,
multiple "New York Times" bestselling author.
Wharton's most popular professor of all time,
like named the most, but, you know
he's got millions of views on his TED Talks.
He's just an incredible person.
And his focus is really on trying to help people
figure out how to live and pursue
meaningful professional lives.
Like it's all about like, work-life,
he's got a podcast called, "Work Life".
Anyway, he's got a new book out called, "Think Again".
And so he's very much in the press at the moment.
And he wrote a "New York Times" op-ed, the other day,
that was kind of relevant to what we were talking about
with Giorgio and Arthur,
in that it was about how you interface with
and communicate with people
who have a very different perspective
on either an issue or a worldview.
And our inclination is to kind of come at them with facts
about why they're wrong and why you're right.
But that never seems to work.
And his ultimate conclusion is really,
we need to enter into these kinds of exchanges
from a perspective of empathy and curiosity
and a true desire to try to understand,
like from a question-asking perspective,
as opposed to an indicting kind of,
you know, telling point of view.
Yeah.
And that's relevant, I think,
when, you know, we're in a divided state at the moment
and whether it's politics or some other,
you know, choose your issue,
everybody's in their information silo and being, you know,
fed a certain type of news that,
you know, satisfies their respective cognitive bias.
And it's important for us to understand
that just because we see other people
with their cognitive biases,
doesn't mean that we don't have our own,
we all have urethritis own.
And in order to kind of create
that ability to communicate healthily,
we need to be objective about our own biases.
And I think when you endeavor to communicate
with another person from that perspective of curiosity,
you're in a position to perhaps,
learn something that you wouldn't otherwise.
Yeah, and I liked it because, you know,
I definitely fall prey to like my emotions
when I get like locking horns
on like these issues that I find so important
because they are so relevant to like, people's lives, right?
So you wanna,
I try to tilt towards justice and in that realm
and you know, everyone getting equal opportunity
and feeling good in life or having opportunities.
So, when I end up locking horns,
I typically do get a little too emotional.
So it was really helpful to see it laid out
because the times I've been effective at communication
has always been when I've been more, you know,
taking a step back and just ask simple questions.
Right.
It's a really great article.
I can't wait to read the book
because one point he makes is
process matters in these conversations
and how you approach these things matters
and who you are and how you feel about yourself, ultimately.
Right.
So there's that take home, as well, yeah.
So more on that, in my conversation with Adam to come.
Looking forward to that one.
All right, listener questions.
All right.
Let's cue it up.
Hey Rich and Adam,
my name is Kevin from the St. Louis area.
And I have a question about productivity of sorts.
So I'm sitting here today,
watching the events unfold at the Capitol Building,
trying to comprehend what's going on
and how we've gotten to this point.
I'm also using this time amongst other times in 2020
to reflect on my privileges, actions
and my role for a better tomorrow.
I also have full-time studies as a medical student,
that today in particular,
I find very difficult to focus on.
In the midst of a global pandemic, as well,
I'm finding it difficult to be productive.
I feel the expectations of my position as a student
and during normal times,
school is hard enough as it is,
My mind tells me that what I'm doing
has less importance when our country is hurting so much.
My question for you, and Rich,
is your advice on how to focus on school
and maybe for others, their job,
and to maintain some semblance
of what you're supposed to be doing
amidst all that's going on.
I'm finding it hard at times
to get in a groove with all of this.
Thanks for all your insights and discussion to both of you.
They mean a lot to me.
Have a good one, thanks, bye.
All right, thanks Kevin, for that question.
Obviously, this question was lodged some weeks ago
in the midst of the insurrection.
And I think, you know,
the sentiment that he's conveying
is pretty human and pretty normal.
I suspect, you know, a lot of people will relate to that.
And it's indicative of, you know,
a very strange and extraordinary time
that we're all living through.
I mean, we're all trying to do our best.
I was glued to that screen.
We're holding ourselves to a standard of behavior
of how we would operate in a normal situation
and these are not normal situations.
So the first thing I would say is like,
give yourself a break a little bit right now,
be a little gracious with yourself.
And that's not to say, let yourself off the hook,
but I think it's okay to take a breather
and not beat yourself up for feeling unproductive
in this moment.
In terms of how to move forward.
I mean, my advice is pretty straight forward
and simple and basic.
I mean, the first thing is try to control the controllables.
There's so much about this, that we have no control over.
We have no agency over it.
The only things we do have control over
is our behaviors and our thoughts and our interactions.
You're in medical school,
so what's the thing in front of you
that you need to get done?
And break those tasks down into bite-sized chunks
and try to execute on them in the best way possible.
Just do the least amount that you need to do
to engender a little bit of momentum
and just look for the next right thing.
You know, I think it's incumbent upon you
as a medical student and somebody who's clearly very busy,
it's okay to take a break from the news.
Like, the news will be the news
and you don't have to be, you know,
hamstrung in your life because of the news cycle.
Like you can take that in chunks, as well,
at certain points of the day, if you feel you need to,
but the news will continue and exist,
whether you're consuming it or not.
I also sense a little bit of guilt or maybe even shame.
Like, I feel that this person feels like
they wanna contribute and be of service
in a way that they're not feeling connected to
in the moment.
And I think it's important to just figure out
how to be a giver in your own way.
That doesn't mean that you have to raise your hand
and be some kind of prominent voice in a political movement
but in your own universe,
you can be of service to,
I don't know if you're dealing with patients yet,
but your fellow students and your professors.
Like how can you exercise small gestures
in a giving type of way
that make you feel more connected to the people around you
and engender, you know, a tighter community.
On the privilege piece,
look, you know, it's fine to acknowledge your privilege,
but I don't think that you should feel guilty
about the position that you're in.
I'm sure you worked very hard to be where you're at
and you know, if there's anything,
you don't have to atone for it, but like,
you should make the most of it.
And just to be the best doctor that you can be
in service to other people.
So to the extent that you may not be able
to make a difference, you know, geopolitically,
you can find meaning and fulfillment in your work
and that is your unique lever for making a difference.
And I think as a doctor,
you can make a tremendous amount of difference
in so many people's lives.
So give yourself a break.
It's a pandemic, things are weird.
They're hard.
It's all okay.
Just do what's in front of you.
Beautiful, I agree.
I think sometimes like these bigger storylines
that are floating over us,
they take on this incredible importance
because they call into question kind of these stories
that we've been telling ourselves about who we are
and where we live and what the people around us are up to.
And they're paralyzing, also.
And they're paralyzing.
but in reality, real life happens super local.
It's on the ground right around you.
And all of that, unless we lived in DC,
it didn't affect us really, like.
So, it affected us emotionally,
but it wasn't like, it didn't change our abilities
to move around in our localities.
Right.
And so, I think you're right, like finding,
keeping it super local, keeping it simple sometimes
is the answer.
But you know, that's coming from a guy
who literally couldn't do anything for like five days.
So I'm with you. (laughing)
I'm with you, St. Louis.
Alright, let's go to John.
All right.
John, from Sierra Nevada.
Hi guys, my name's John.
I live in the Sierra Nevada mountains in California.
And my question for you guys is more so directed at Rich
but you know, how do you address failure?
Like the colossal type of failure,
the type of failure that makes you feel like
your life's falling apart or you know,
the wheels are falling off
and you can't grab onto the reins
and get control of things again.
You know what the higher version of yourself needs to do
but you can't do it because all you can feel
is the lower version of yourself, you know?
And how do you tackle things like guilt and shame
and how do you address and like adjust your lifestyle
to set yourself up for success?
Anyway, thank you guys.
I love the show.
I love you guys.
You've done a lot for me and I appreciate it.
Thanks again, bye.
That's heavy.
Hmm.
I can feel the pain in this one.
Yeah.
It's tough.
You know, it sounds like John's going through
something extremely difficult.
We don't know the details of what that is
but I intuit a sense of powerlessness
in what he's relating, right?
It's the idea of the two wolves,
like which wolf do you feed?
And the dark wolf is the one
who's getting the best of him at the moment.
And there's a sense of an inability
to kind of arrest that negative impulse.
And I know what that feels like.
It's really hard.
And you know, for me, that was in the form of alcoholism
and the solution that I had to come to
was breaking the chains of denial
and throwing my hands up in the air
and literally surrendering,
rather than trying to control it, letting go,
and letting go for me, meant letting other people in.
So I think the first thing I would say to John is,
you know, I'm empathetic and I feel you.
And I think the first thing that you can do
to try to get on top of this
is to confront those feelings
rather than repress them or compartmentalize them
to find a way to bring voice to them.
Because things like shame can't survive the light.
You've got to shine the light on them.
And that's scary.
It takes courage to communicate with another person
about what you're really going through.
It requires a certain vulnerability
and it's very frightening,
but I can't encourage you enough,
how important it is to find somebody
that you feel comfortable talking to,
that you can be really honest with,
that you can convey whatever it is specifically,
particularly specifically.
I think it's important to be really specific
to let somebody in on this
and the relief that you'll experience,
just in that alone, I think is tremendous.
You have to find the right person,
somebody you can trust,
somebody that you respect,
somebody that can provide you with solid counsel.
But I think the process of that communication is of itself,
a little bit of a letting go
and it will allow you to get a little more objectivity
on what's happening with you
to help you find the cause,
the triggers of those behaviors
that are sending you sideways and ultimately,
help you analyze this story that you're telling yourself,
that you're a failure and you can't help yourself
and everything's out of control,
to really deconstruct that
and perhaps construct a better, healthier,
less negative story for yourself.
You know, along the way,
can you find a way to listen to that,
you know, positive wolf, at all?
Can you make any kind of lifestyle adjustments
that would move you in a positive direction?
In recovery, they call it taking contrary action.
So when your instinct is, you know,
whether it's like, ah, I know I shouldn't drink
but I'm gonna take that drink, whatever it is,
like what is the contrary action?
Like, oh, I don't wanna pick up the phone
and tell that guy, what I just did.
The contrary action is to pick up the phone
and tell the guy what you did, right?
What is the smallest contrary action that you can take
that will break the seal on that and, you know,
initiate a different direction for yourself?
That's a great little,
super doable action step to do.
Like, if your mind is telling you one thing
and you know that's the negative thing,
just do the smallest version of that.
Yeah, what would the good version of myself do?
And as heavy as that phone is or whatever it is,
you know, how difficult it is,
if you can just do that one thing
and you're like, wow, I did that and I didn't die.
Yeah.
Right.
I think the other thing is
to reframe this word failure
and recast it as learning,
like I don't know what this failure,
colossal type of failure is, specifically again,
that you're experiencing,
but can we look at it instead as a learning experience?
Like what can be gleaned from whatever it is
that you're going through that you can then leverage
to be better and grow?
And I think in truth, success is about failure.
There isn't success that exists outside of failure.
Success is about trying.
It's about not being afraid to fail
and not taking failures personally.
And the thing that you're attempting to do
may have failed but it's important
to depersonalize yourself from that.
You didn't fail.
This thing failed.
You had the courage to try.
So can you disassociate your identity,
your sense of self,
from the thing itself so that your identity
isn't tied up in how the thing does,
if that makes sense, right?
That way you create a little bit of distance
between yourself, your identity and your actions.
And at the same time,
keep showing up at the plate and, you know, swing the bat.
Because if there's one trait that successful people share,
it's that they fail way more than they succeed.
They just try so often and so regularly
and we forget about the failures,
we only see the successes.
And this is another message or theme of Adam Grant's work.
Like his book "Originals" was all about this.
Like what makes people originals?
And he looks at all these successful people
and realizes like, these people failed all the time,
whether it's Picasso
or Edison, like they have tons of failures in their wakes.
And we don't look at those or think about those.
We just focus on the few successes they had
but they took more bats at plate than anybody else.
So if you can reframe this whole thing
from that perspective,
that might make it easier to get back up to the plate
and swing again.
And really try to objectively deconstruct
what you're going through and find the lessons in there.
And if you can do that
and start figuring out how to implement those lessons
to craft a better version of yourself,
five years from now, you could look back on
whatever it is you're going through right now and say,
that was the best thing that ever happened to me.
And that sounds glib.
And I don't mean to be insensitive
to what you're going through,
but I've heard this, I've experienced this myself.
And I know so many other people that have
and maybe that'll provide you with a little sliver of hope
to dig a little bit deeper to get yourself out of this hole.
Yeah.
When I hear his message,
I think of myself, 40 years old, marriage fell apart,
"Lonely Planet" jobs like going away,
because maybe "Lonely Planet" is failing.
That was what was happening then.
And that was the worry, then, didn't fail.
But I saw all my income going away
which wasn't that huge of an income anyway.
I saw my identity as a travel writer, adventurer,
going away.
I didn't have the life I thought I'd had.
And then that was just the beginning of like,
it seemed like everything was working against me,
just like one thing after another.
And it's hard not to take things personally
when it just keeps,
you just feel like you're in a vicious cycle.
And so I totally feel that.
And I know how that can, I know how that is.
So, you know, the only thing is,
it's like weather, eventually that luck turns,
especially if you take these small steps,
like Rich laid out.
I would add just like, sometimes it helps,
if in the morning you could do one thing physically
that is not,
whether it's do 10 sun salutations
or sit down and try to meditate for five or 10 minutes
and turn your brain off, if you can.
I mean, it's hard to at first,
but like, one physical thing you can do,
first thing in the morning,
right when you get up.
So at least that time, right after that,
you kind of feel good.
Yeah, a little self care.
Just a little bit.
And to quote, Karamo,
can you look at this as something that is happening
not to you, but for you?
And that's beautiful, I love that,
yeah, I love that.
And I say that you have your version of this story.
Look, you know, I've hit bottom as an alcoholic.
I've been unemployable.
I've been in a situation
where my family didn't want anything to do with me.
I've had cars repossessed.
I almost lost my house.
I've been unable to pay my bill.
I've had so many, you know, versions of
feeling like a failure
and have been able to claw out of it.
So I don't know what John's circumstances are
but I do believe and trust that no matter where he is,
there is a better place for him.
And there's always light at the end of the tunnel.
There you go.
All right, one last one from Phoenix, Arizona.
Hi, my name is Sarah
and I live in Phoenix, Arizona.
And I'm wondering if you're willing to discuss
just something interesting that I've noticed.
So I'm in my first year of sobriety
after a long struggle with drugs and alcohol.
I am a long-time athlete playing lots of sports
and loving running.
And I was wondering if you were willing to discuss
how overcoming substance abuse has changed your mindset
on fitness, your life, your goals, your athleticism,
just things like that.
I'm a huge fan of the show
and I'm super happy to even reach out,
but hopefully, you'll
address these kinds of things in the talk
because your story is really powerful.
And I think it would empower a lot of other people
to take hold of their life, their bodies, their fitness.
Thanks again.
And I hope that y'all are having a wonderful day.
Cool, thanks for the questions, Sarah.
Congrats on a year of sobriety, that's a huge deal.
Amazing and it's a great question.
It's an interesting question.
I mean, the first thing I would say is,
sobriety first.
Like, don't be confused.
Like, there is a confused narrative out there
that somehow like being vegan
or being an athlete
contributed to me getting sober and staying sober.
And that's just not what happened at all.
Like, I didn't get and stay sober
because I went vegan or became an endurance athlete,
I got and stayed sober by overcoming denial,
finding people to talK to,
being honest, holding myself accountable,
working a program in the secret rooms
and helping others and working with a sponsor
and doing an inventory and making amends.
And it's really only when
I created a solid foundation of sobriety
that I began to expand in other areas
like being vegan and becoming
this middle-aged endurance athlete,
came many years after.
I got sober at 31.
I didn't start doing Ultras until I was 42.
I got, you know, I went vegan at 40.
So there's a decade after getting sober
where I was trying to sort my shit out
and get my life back on track
before any of these other things.
So this idea, this notion that addictive personality
can just go from one thing to then you can put an athlete,
you can make them an athlete instead, and he can channel.
And that compensates.
I mean, you could.
It's just, that's not how it played out for me.
Like I had a decade of, you know,
being a workaholic and like eating shitty food.
I transferred many addictive tendencies
on to other things that weren't drugs or alcohol.
And it took me a long time in my spiritual evolution
to like grapple with those things.
And as they say, the road gets narrower.
Like when you first get sober,
just to not drink, is everything, right?
Anything else is fine.
It's just like, just don't drink, right?
And then the more emotionally sober you get,
the less tolerant you become of other behaviors
and proclivities that you have that used to not bother you.
Like, you just can't get away with it anymore
because the more emotionally sober and mature you become,
you realize that those things are at odds
with you being the most, you know,
actualized person that you can be.
So whether it's, you know,
going to gamble or shopping too much
or working whatever, you know, shitty self-care habits,
whatever it is, like those things become,
if you get sober enough,
they become unbearable and they have to go, as well.
And this is, it's called slowbriety.
It takes a long time.
So in my case, these things didn't happen in lockstep.
And so I just wanna impress upon anybody who's listening
to understand that things like, you know,
running, cycling, just, you know, self care,
physical fitness, diet, sleep, meditation,
these things are all beneficial to sobriety.
And meditation is actually a core aspect of sobriety,
but none of them can take the place of working a program.
And I know there's various different ways
of getting sober and staying sober, but, you know,
I got sober in 12 step and that got me sober.
It's kept me sober.
It's still the most important thing in my life.
I tried all these other ways.
They didn't work.
This is just work what works for me.
But I will say in more specific response to your question,
that getting sober
led to performing more esteemable acts
on behalf of myself and behalf of other people.
And esteemable acts, in turn,
lead to elevated self-esteem, which in turn,
expands your horizon of what's possible for yourself.
In other words, you begin to believe in yourself.
You begin to believe that you can do more
and you can be more.
And that means that you end up taking on things
that you never would have previously.
You get more interested in bettering yourself
and in improving the quality of life of those around you
and challenges that once might've seemed impossible,
you end up welcoming.
And in my case, that took the form
of these endurance challenges,
and later writing books, starting this podcast.
For you, it's gonna be different, of course.
But these are all practices that contribute
and reinforce my sobriety,
but they're not
interchangeable with the program itself.
Running specifically, I think is interesting.
I think swimming is the same way
as this practice of active meditation.
It's something that's very honest and keeps you honest.
It doesn't care who you think you are,
who you tell yourself you are,
who you tell other people you know, who you are,
because it tells you who you are.
And that makes it this amazing and beautiful template
for self-discovery and self-improvement,
and it's just one of the reasons
why I love endurance sports and that's all great.
Just don't replace a program,
your program for running as a solution.
Boom.
That's it.
We did this.
That's good.
How do you feel?
I feel good, man and that was-
It feels good man.
It feels good man, to like, unload the-
There was a lot chambered.
There was like six weeks of "Roll On" energy
that needed to be expressed.
I don't know how long you've been going on for,
but this was like a pressure valve.
It's a filibuster, we're filibustering.
(men laughing)
It felt good, man.
You know, I've wanted to talk to you about this.
I even suggested we do a remote one, like, you know-
Yeah, I know.
And you texted me and you're like,
let's do, we gotta do,
maybe you could do the thing, let's go live.
We gotta talk about this.
And I was tempted, but I was like, no, I'm not working.
I cannot do this, so.
No, no, no, yeah, yeah.
I'm glad you didn't.
It was worth waiting.
You know, it's funny, like there's the thing in journalism,
the later you are, the smarter you have to be.
And so I think it was good.
You brought Arthur and Giorgio in.
(Rich laughing)
'Cause they look, they make both of us look smarter!
Yes, exactly, right. (laughing)
They made it seem like we actually know
what we're talking about.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
No, I mean, it's amazing how much they know
the inner workings.
Right.
And it sounds like Arthur's connected to Anonymous.
Yeah, he was cagey about that.
Yeah, that was interesting.
Yeah, maybe we'll do a little research on that.
Who knows?
We should also point out
that there's been lots of interesting articles
that Adam and I read in preparation
to talk about the subjects today,
which we'll link up in the show notes.
Some cool pieces by Taylor Lorenz and Kevin Roose,
of course, who are the two journalists
that I follow the most
to stay on top of these particular issues,
as well as that Politico piece on Holly
and some other things.
So check the show notes for that.
We will be back here in two weeks time.
In the meantime, follow Adam at Adam Skolnick.
You can leave us a message.
If you would like your question
considered for the podcast.
That number again is (424) 235-4626.
I already told you guys to check out the show notes
on the episode page at Richroll.com.
Don't forget to hit that subscribe button on YouTube,
Apple, Spotify, wherever you listen to podcasts.
Again, we did create a clips channel on YouTube.
So if you do dig short chunks from the show,
or you wanna just sample a guests before committing,
you can find a link to that channel in the show notes
or just search Rich Roll podcast clips on YouTube.
That's it.
Appreciate the love, you guys.
See you back here in a couple of days with,
who's coming up next?
Oh, Alexi Pappas.
Oh.
That's a good one.
That's good.
Yeah.
Yeah, have you checked out our book, "Bravey"?
Not yet, not yet.
It's really good, she's a great writer.
I have to, it's getting so much love
and I can't wait to-
I know, Jake Tapper, tweeting about it.
Come on!
I mean, she's one of those-
Adam Grant blurbed it!
I know.
It's unbelievable.
You know what?
I think that's an audio book because she's so cool.
I wanna hear her read it.
She's super cool.
So, I think that's an audio book.
I've got credits.
I'm with you on that.
I'm gonna grab it.
Cool, all right you guys.
See you back here soon.
Much love, peace.
Namaste.